Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt, mein Name ist Tim.
Und heute ist der neunzehnte Juni zwanzig zwanzig und es wird Zeit für ein Corona Weekly und ich sage hallo zu Pavel und Pavel.
Pavel, Pavel Meyer und jetzt quatschen wir hier schon seit Monaten. Ähm
über die ganze Corona äh Krise und äh auf diesem Kanal war diese Woche eine Menge los in dieser Hinsicht, auch wenn ich äh zwischendurch auch mal wieder geschafft habe, mal was zum Brexit zu bringen, also
zwischendurch als kleine Aufhalterung. Aber darum geht's heute nicht, sondern es geht wie immer um.
Ja die fortschreitende Dauer,
die sich ja in Deutschland nicht ganz so wild zeigt.
Zumindest derzeit noch.
Da sahen wir gleich was dazu. International, global auf jeden Fall noch voll am wütend ist in so einigen Ländern. Sieht gar nicht so gut aus und wir werden jetzt hier auch gleich nochmal schauen.
Wie es denn eigentlich bei uns aussieht. Fangen wir damit doch mal an.
Ja, bei uns bisher vielleicht was bisher geschah.
Preview und UKW.
Ja. Genau. War das ja eigentlich äh so den Trend sehen konnten, dass es äh in Deutschland eigentlich jede Woche.
Weniger Fälle geworden sind, weniger Infektionen. Natürlich immer,
wochentags Schwankungen und äh so weiter, aber grundsätzlich gegen die Zahlen runter. So nicht super schnell, aber äh sie gingen runter
in der Summe in Deutschland, aber es gab halt so einen
paar Hotspots, das heißt, das Schienen sich zu konzentrieren. Es gab mehr und mehr Landkreise, die halt Chorona frei, also supergrün waren und äh ja, ein paar die.
Nicht so toll waren oder die, die halt eher Hotspots waren. So.
Dass scheint sich jetzt leider etwas zu ändern. Also.
Zum einen äh reicht jetzt der Rückgang in im Gro der Landkreise nicht mehr aus
um das Anwachsen äh in den Hotspots vollständig zu kompensieren. Es ist leider auch so, dass mittlerweile in einem Drittel aller Landkreise, die Zahlen,
steigen. So und wenn ich mal die Zahlen steigen, dann meine ich damit jeweils das in den letzten sieben Tagen mehr infizierte gemeldet wurden
als in den sieben Tagen davor und sagen so ein vierzehn.
Ages, Rückblick und das ist natürlich.
Bedenklich. So, das ist nicht schön und wenn das so weitergeht äh wird das nichts.
Als.
Aber grundsätzlich, aber größer ist, ich haben wir ja niedrige Zahlen, das heißt, selbst wenn wir einen Anstieg haben, bewegen wir uns immer noch im niedrigen Zahlenbereich.
Ja, es ist äh also wir sind insgesamt,
auf einem Niveau, was sag mal, akzeptabel ist, natürlich die Frage für wen
aber akzeptabel für unser Gesundheitssystem erstmal, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass wir äh wieder unmittelbar davor stehen, dass unser Gesundheitssystem überfordert ist und
weil um was weiteres positives reinzubringen.
Der erwartete schnelle wieder ausbruch nach ja Rückfahren der Maßnahmen oder nachdem ja jetzt Kontaktverbote zurückgefahren wurden und das öffentliche Leben so langsam wieder zunimmt,
hätte es ja Schulen und so weiter hätte es.
Deutlich schlimmer kommen können, muss man tatsächlich auch sagen und.
Gerade in Amerika wundert man sich halt auch so ein bisschen, wie so die Zahlen bei uns nicht so richtig hochgehen, aber vielleicht ist es auch nur.
Irgendwie ein kleines Internet so, was wir gerade sehen aus vollkommen unbekannten Gründen, aber es sieht,
halt nicht danach aus, so dass das Muster, also das Verteilungsmuster,
ist eben äh so, dass es jetzt sich offenbar wieder so ein bisschen in die in die Breite, äh also die Infektion wieder ein bisschen in die Breite gegangen sind. Also sowohl auf Landkreisebene und wenn man auf äh.
Jetzt Bundeslandebene geht, sieht man halt auch, dass in sieben von sechzehn Ländern.
Zahlen steigen. Sachsen-Anhalt,
hat's jetzt sogar auf Tabellenplatz drei meiner Risikotabelle geschafft, obwohl da,
absolut relativ wenig los ist, aber in Sachsen-Anhalt haben sich die Fellheit in einer Woche verdreifacht. Von einem sagen mittleren Niveau
aus. Und wenn die sich jetzt nochmal verdreifachen, äh dann hätten sie halt ähm Anrecht auf eine Spitzen.
Platz äh von dem sie dann Berlin verdrängen könnten. Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass es passiert, aber ja, äh Berlin.
Berlin finde ich wirklich beunruhigend. Also in Berlin gehen fast in allen Bezirken
äh die Zahlen hoch, mit Ausnahme jetzt von drei Bezirken, haben wir steigende Zahlen und insbesondere in Neukölln.
Ist offenbar richtig was los, da haben sich die Zahlen verdreieinhalbfacht,
so von dreiunddreißig auf hundertsechsundzwanzig Fälle und da ist natürlich die Frage
was ist da los? Und da kann man aber auch erstmal nur sagen, ja, es gibt auf der einen Seite eben Hotspots, aber es gibt offensichtlich auch in den meisten Bezirken,
entweder genauso viele Fälle wie in den Vorwochen oder die Zahlen sind,
ein bisschen oder eben deutlich höher gegangen, Trypto-Köpenick, verdoppelt, Mitte zwanzig Prozent mehr, Kreuzberg.
Siebzig Prozent mehr reinigen darf, achtzig Prozent mehr,
Das ist schon nicht einfach nur so kleine Schwankungen, sondern dass es ist einfach auffällig. So, dass die Situation in Berlin was
deswegen auch zurecht die Risikoliste aller Bundesländer und.
Anführt. Ähm ja, ist halt nicht nicht ohne Grund. Und.
Mir wurde halt kolportiert unter der Hand äh würden die Ärzte sich davon reden,
von sogenannten Ramadan Clustern an der Stelle, was da mal doppelt.
Problematisch ist äh natürlich einmal, haben wir gesehen äh wie sehr
äh so auch durch Corona in manchen Ländern des Fremdenfeindlichkeitsvorschub gegeben hat und ja offiziell hört man aber,
eher wenig. Es hat da halt diesen äh Wohnblock in äh Neukölln gegeben, der komplett unter Quarantäne steht
wo äh ja, dann jemand vom Gesundheitsamt wohl auch gesagt hat, ja, die kennen wir alle, das sind alles
ähm ja eher bildungsferne, sozial, schwache Leute, die gar nicht verstehen zum Teil, was hier passiert und ähm ja
da gab's natürlich dann auch wieder Gegenkritik zu, aber Problem ist eigentlich,
Ähm das ist halt so eine wieder so eine einzelne, anektotische Geschichte und wir wissen.
Nicht wirklich und mit wir meine ich jetzt die Öffentlichkeit, wie denn die Verbreitung jetzt gerade eigentlich stattfindet und vonstatten geht und wo jetzt tatsächlich
Leute infiziert sind, wie viele Cluster gibt es eigentlich? Das haben wir ja ständig schon.
Eingefordert, äh, dass die Gesundheitsämter doch bitte auch diese Daten veröffentlichen mögen, damit man eine Orientierung hatte, damit man.
Einfach ein bisschen besser sein individuelles Verhalten drauf. Einstellen kann. Und so wie sich mir jetzt.
Die Situation darstellt, sieht es so aus, es gibt ein paar große Cluster, aber es gibt eben auch die große Fläche und da ist Berlin.
Sogar so etwas wie Symptomatisch eigentlich fürs ganze Land, wo derselbe äh Zustand besteht.
Und es sieht halt so aus, als würde es.
Zum einen an bestimmten Stellen richtig reinschlagen, aber auch in der Breite irgendwie langsam hochkochen,
und letzteres ist natürlich die dann die große Gefahr, weil das natürlich viel schwieriger zu kontrollieren ist auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite.
Gut besteht dann wieder die Theorie, sowas läuft sich dann eher schneller Tod, äh wenn man's weiß, aber wenn's jetzt
hunderte von Einzelfällen äh sind, dann stelle ich mir das verdammt schwierig vor und jeder hat dann so fünf oder zehn Kontakte und,
da kommen die Gesundheitsämter dann auch ganz schnell wieder.
Wenn das weiter ansteigt, an den Punkt, wo sie es nicht mehr wirklich trecken können und nicht mehr isolieren können und.
Es könnte sogar sein, dass man bereits jetzt gerade an dem Punkt angekommen ist, weil sie nächste Woche und wird uns da genaueres zeigen, eigentlich hatte ich erwartet oder gehofft.
Das speziell in Berlin, das nur so ein Peak ist aufgrund einiger Ausbrüche und die zahlen sich dann wieder stabilisieren oder wieder sogar sinken, aber,
das sieht gerade gar nicht so aus. Und.
Wenn man das hochrechnet, wenn das so weitergeht, dann sind wir in vier Wochen am Ende der Fahnenstange angekommen,
und dann äh werden neue Einschränkungen und umgänglich Seiten, damit man wieder massiv anziehen müsste, wenn wir da Sachen schließen müssen, äh wieder das Kontaktverbot ausweiten, weil,
so wie es im Moment läuft, kann's nicht weitergehen, ja? Weder in Berlin noch deutschlandweit.
Jetzt äh ist es natürlich so.
Wir haben deutschlandweit natürlich jetzt auch diese diese super Fälle, also hier jetzt gerade wieder Schlachterei äh Tennis, irgendwie laut Medienberichten siebenhundertfünfzig Leute, positiv getestet haben.
Krasse Nummer. Die Zahlen sind glaube ich jetzt noch nicht alle durchgehend veröffentlicht. Heute kamen so ein größerer Schwung dazu, ne, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Näher bisher, also Gütersloh habe ich bisher dreihundertzweiundvierzig Fälle in den letzten sieben Tagen äh sieben, siebzig in Warendorf und vermutlich wird.
Ist auch noch in anderen umliegenden Landkreisen äh.
Fälle gegeben haben, aber ich denke, es kommt auch noch ein bisschen was nach. So, die sind noch nicht, glaube ich, noch nicht alle komplett prozessiert und erfasst und gemeldet, jedenfalls noch nicht beim RKI angekommen.
Ist jetzt nicht so, dass das jetzt alle Hoffnung verloren ist oder dass man jetzt muss okay, es ist jetzt super viel super viel gefährlicher als in der letzten Woche rauszugehen, aber der allgemeine Trend.
Ist einfach sehr beunruhigend.
Ja, vor allem wäre es ja jetzt eigentlich einer Zeit gewesen, halt das so durchzuhalten. Meine anekotische Evidenz, also ich merke halt, wie Leute jetzt in den geöffneten Bars und so äh
einfach zusammensitzen und keine Masken tragen und äh auch so in die Burger leben, einfach so rein marschieren. Das muss jetzt nicht unbedingt immer gleich wieder
das eigentliche Problem sein, ja, weil das dann oft dann halt auch,
kurze Kontakte sind gut knapp mir jetzt nicht unbedingt so äh so aber dass die Leute dann auch die Masken ÖPNV nicht mehr tragen äh,
ne, also man signalisiert sich damit einfach gegenseitig. So, ja, ach, passt schon. Und dann äh setze ich das natürlich wie so ein Virus.
Dass es da sozusagen der Gegenvirus so dieses so ach, die anderen sind auch entspannt, dann bin ich jetzt auch mal entspannt, weil das ist ja das, was man will. Das ist ja das.
Wonach man sich so sehnt und und und was was irgendwie gefehlt hat. Ach, wie schön das jetzt wieder ist äh in der Sonne zu sitzen und äh man hat ja auch so viel zu bequatschen. Man hat sich ja so lange nicht mehr gesehen und das ist natürlich jetzt so genau, dass,
Problem, was äh das Potential hat, ist auch wieder alles ein bisschen schlimmer werden zu lassen.
Na ja und wir hatten ja auch nicht so super viel Luft nach oben, wenn man jetzt mal.
Sich diesen berühmten Air Faktor anschaut, wo der auf seinem tiefsten Punkt im sieben Tages äh Mittel war, dann
waren wir knapp unter null Komma acht, also nie unter null Komma sieben äh gekommen und haben uns eigentlich eher so in der null Komma acht bis null Komma neuner Region bewegt. Das heißt, bis zu eins
ist es da nicht weit. So, also da ist nicht, da war nicht so viel jetzt Luft nach oben und,
jetzt sieht es gerade so aus, als äh wenn uns äh ja, langsam die Luft ausgeht
Als wenn das jetzt mit den Lockerungen äh oder mit den,
dem allgemeinen Verhalten jetzt an den Punkt kommt, wo wir wieder.
Anziehen müssen. Immer noch ist es, ist es zu kurz, aber ich rechne halt schon immer bei meinen Rechnungen, wie gesagt, mit sieben Tagesdurchschnitten.
Und insofern ist das jetzt nicht nur mal so ein so ein Tagesereignis.
Von dem ich hier jetzt Rede plus, wer jetzt die meisten Sendungen gehört hat.
Wird sicherlich wissen, dass wir mal viel über äh die Faktoren geredet haben, die jetzt.
Die Zahlen, die gemeldet werden, ähm beeinflussen, dass man halt die Zahlen immer im Kontext sehen muss. Und.
Ein wichtiger Faktor am Anfang waren halt die Wochentagsschwankungen, die dann dazu geführt haben, so zur christlichen Logistikfunktion und letztlich zur dann aber Entscheidung einfach nur nicht
immer nur mindestens ganze Wochen äh zu betrachten, weil alles was kürzer ist als eine Woche kann man halt einfach komplett knicken.
In der Betrachtung, da sind einfach die Wochentagsschmankungen zu groß, dann ist.
Aber einen ein weiterer, wichtiger Punkt, natürlich die Ausweitung von Tests oder das runterfahren, von Tests, beziehungsweise, das verändern das Testregimes, die Regeln, wer wie getestet wird und natürlich wenn ich mehr Tests mache.
Finde ich auch mehr. So. Gut, hat zwei Trump auch gesagt, äh so, aber ist jetzt nicht so.
Das ist alleine davon äh abhängen würde, weil ja zu Trump kann man jetzt an mit na ja, wenn wir nicht testen würden, dann hätten wir auch keine Fälle. Äh so.
So, das liegt alles nur am Testen.
Genau so nach dem Motto, wenn wir keine Todeszertifikate mehr ausstellen, dann stirbt auch keiner mehr.
Ja, ja, genau. So ungefähr, aber äh ich ich sage mal, einen.
Kern an Wahrheit steckt natürlich drin, das ist schon die Zahlen äh verzerrt, wenn ich halt die Tests ausweite oder reduziere so. Und da war es so.
Wir waren halt schon mal vor drei Wochen. Relativ nah an der eins dran. So haben halt an der eins gekratzt, aber.
Zu dem Zeitpunkt sind gleichzeitig ist das Testregime geändert worden und die Tests ausgeweitet.
Worden, sodass sich äh einen eigentlichen Großteil dieses Anstiegs.
Eher damit erklären lässt. Also, dass wir damals nicht wirklich über die an die eins rangekommen sind, sondern irgendwo
sich vielleicht gar nicht verändert hatte. Jetzt die Situation aktuell sieht aber leider genau umgekehrt aus, die Testzahlen gehen jetzt
wieder runter. So, aber gleichzeitig ist trotz.
Sinkender Testzahlen äh sind jetzt die Fälle äh einfach äh ja.
Ja, sind sie angestiegen, genau. Und das ist das, was.
Dass halt äh diesmal nicht so schön macht.
Genau. Und nur um jetzt nochmal die die anderen Unsicherheitsfaktoren.
Mal alle aufzuzählen, auf die wir jetzt in den letzten Wochen gestoßen sind, wo wir einen nach dem anderen quasi entdeckt haben, also waren die Wochentagsschwankungen, die Änderungen im Testregime, dann schwankt halt die Dunkelzifferquote, die man auch,
berücksichtigen muss, dann
äh spielt Demographie ja eine Rolle, also in welchen Milieus sich das ausbreiten und mit den Meldeverzögerungen haben wir dann weiten und weiteren Unsicherheitsfaktor und,
das äh ja, macht jetzt die Zahl nicht völlig wertlos, aber ähm ja, die Störeinflüsse sind halt erheblich zum Glück,
gleicht sich vieles so über die Zeit aus, aber man muss halt solche Kurven, die über mehrere Wochen gehen, eben sehr genau anschauen, weil das nicht alles wirklich vergleichbar ist oder wir nicht das messen, was wir zu messen glauben,
immer. Und auch auf der Basis der Zahl der Toten, die ein bisschen stabiler ist, die halt nicht so fehlerhaft ist, die.
Läuft irgendwie in die selbe Richtung, wobei das halt auch merkwürdig ist, weil sie das nicht tun sollte, also.
Aber ähm die Zahlen sehen nicht gut aus. Können wir mal äh so äh zusammenfassen. Nicht kritisch, aber wenn das jetzt nicht nächste Woche sich umkehrt,
so, dann haben wir ein echtes Problem, dann haben wir äh ja, dann haben wir eine Schlacht verloren. So, dann müssen wir irgendwie wieder rückzug und äh neu angreifen.
Ja, ist die Frage, wie man äh das dann macht. Also, was was wäre denn jetzt sozusagen die Maßnahmen, die man ähm da vor Ort nennen könnte? Also ich denke, wo ist auf jeden Fall Potential gibt, wäre einfach diese Maskenpflicht, ähm stärker durchzusetzen.
Also in Berlin wird ja jetzt auch schon über Bußgelder äh diskutiert, et cetera
ähm zumal sich ja gezeigt hat in zahlreichen Studien jetzt ähm auch so aus eigener Erfahrung, dass Jena Beispiel, dass das eben allein schon ein extrem,
wirkungsvoller Faktor ist. Ja, dass dass man einfach sagt, so ja, muss er einfach jetzt sein. Und wir äh Policen das auch in gewisser Hinsicht ein bisschen.
Ja, keine Ahnung, Ordnungsamt im Supermarkt oder was weiß ich, äh vielleicht wäre es äh auch mal eine Gelegenheit. Ich weiß gar nicht, wird eigentlich sind eigentlich die Kontrolleure im im ÖPNV schon wieder unterwegs oder,
sind die alle noch im Urlaub. So, ich meine, die können ja sich vielleicht mal ein bisschen mehr auf die Masken konzentrieren, als auf die Tickets. Das geht auch schneller
ähm das wäre auf jeden Fall hilfreich, ja? Also, einfach sagst du, ja, ist mir jetzt egal, ob du ein Ticket hast, aber wenn du eine Maske hast, dann kommst du hier nicht rein.
Fertig. So und äh das das das führt natürlich dann zu einer gewissen Neuens und wird auch jetzt nicht jeder mitgehen und wie das eben so ist, ne, aber ähm,
muss auch nicht unbedingt gleichen Bußgeld äh verhängt werden. Es wäre halt gut, wenn das im Raum steht. Ja, man muss ja nicht gleich mit der vollen Keule immer zuschlagen, sondern sagen so, ja okay, eigentlich müsste ich dir jetzt hier was ich betrag X abnehmen, aber
ist jetzt einfach mal raus, holst du eine scheiß Maske und dann.
Dann ist auch erstmal gut in der ersten Woche und dann kann man ja mal sehen, wie sich das äh entwickelt. Und das würde wahrscheinlich schon eine ganze Menge bringen. Hast du noch andere Vorschläge.
Eine Sache ist so, dass halt die Situation der Leute sehr unterschiedlich.
Sind. Und gerade Leute, die viele Schulpflichtige, Kinder haben. Ich habe hier in der Nachtbarschaft mit.
Leuten, Müttern äh vor allem gesprochen, die dann so drei oder vier Kinder auf drei oder vier verschiedenen Schulen haben. Ich meine
das Problem und äh die drehen langsam echt am Rad
ähm so, weil offiziell zwar jetzt wieder das langsam mit der Schule losgeht, aber so richtig ist es dann doch wieder nicht losgegangen und äh so. Eine Sache dann
gibt's natürlich verschiedene Berufsträger, die halt in
in nach wie vor in Kontakt mit mit Leuten äh kommen und äh ja, Anforderungen von Unternehmen, also will nur sagen, es wird jetzt.
Nicht mal ein bisschen schwieriger so diese diese eine Lösung für alle anzubieten, sondern eigentlich wär's gut, äh wenn.
Man hinreichend differenzierte,
Informationen hätte so, wo ist es denn jetzt grade gefährlich? Was sind denn so die Gefahrensituationen, in denen ich mich besonders schützen muss oder wo ich mich raushalten muss, wie viele Leute stecken sich denn im ÖPNV an? Wie gefährlich äh ist denn der
wie gefährlich ist es denn eigentlich einkaufen zu gehen? Wie gefährlich ist es eigentlich meine Kinder in die Schule äh zu,
schicken, so äh wie gefährlich ist es eigentlich in die Kneipe,
zu gehen gerade. So, wie gefährlich ist es im Fitness äh Studio, ja? Und da haben wir nach wie vor wirklich
null Hinweise drauf. Dabei äh müssten zumindest die Gesundheitsempfehlungen, die erfassen ja sagen sämtliche Kontakte und versuchen ja auch rauszufinden, wer sich wo angesteckt hat. Das heißt, die müssten eigentlich einen,
ganz gutes äh zumindest einen Überblick, euer Anhaltspunkte äh geben können über das Infektionsgeschehen, aber
Ich sehe da nichts, hast du irgendwie irgendwo was äh gelesen oder könntest du mir irgendwie sagt, dienliche Hinweise äh geben auf die Fragen, äh die ich gerade äh,
gestellt.
Nee, also aus außerdem, was jetzt äh äh im im im Newsflow so im Mittelpunkt steht, so, ne, also Stichwort hier Tönis, äh Fleischfabrik, Unterkünfte von.
Von so, ich weiß gar nicht, was überhaupt den, deren Beschäftigungsmodell äh ist, dass so Zeitarbeiter oder so.
Werkverträge.
Also sie arbeiten da eigentlich schon dauerhaft, sind aber nicht offiziell angestellt, sondern über irgend so eine.
Freie Mitarbeiter im Prinzip oder ich agis oder wie auch immer, dass früher genannt.
Selbstständigkeit.
Genau, genau, schein Selbstständige.
Nicht eigentlich schon längst äh verhindert werden. Na ja, also auf jeden Fall das ist auf jeden Fall auch ein Problem, aber es ist auf jeden Fall auch nicht das einzige Problem. An der Stelle aber ich stimme dir zu, es gibt einfach relativ wenig.
Informationen dadrüber, was es jetzt eigentlich genau.
Wo findet es eigentlich statt? Zu Hause, draußen, Arbeit, Freizeit, Schule, so das sind ja eigentlich Fragen, die haben uns hier.
Von Anfang angestellt und haben gesagt, na ja, mal gucken und die Zeit wird's schon bringen und derzeit haben die noch was anderes zu tun und so weiter. Mittlerweile würde man ja mal meinen.
Könnte das ja durchaus mal auch generiert worden sein. Wir haben ja nun schon mehrfach den den mangelnden Informationsflow da beklagt ähm.
So richtig was verbessert hat sich daran, die auch nicht, oder? Hat sich eine Daten irgendwas verbessert?
Ne, also auch an den Daten hat sich,
eigentlich nichts verbessert. Es gab ja da den den Appell der Datenjournalisten auch mit ganz klaren äh.
Ten und wünschen, aber ja, geändert hat sich da nicht viel.
Wir haben immer noch immer noch NPDFs gucken, um
dann die Summe der Zahlen der Tests in der letzten Woche.
Zu sehen, weil offensichtlich obwohl das eigentlich gesetzlich,
äh vorgeschrieben war, das sind wohl nicht pünktlich geklappt, dass die Zahlen jetzt äh also die Testzahlen von den Laboren direkt ans RKI gemeldet werden, das scheint irgendwie auch noch zu stoppen,
so habe ich gelesen, weil die technischen Voraussetzungen wohl noch nicht gegeben sind,
was auch immer, dass das bedeuten mag, also ja, plus.
So, ich habe das Gefühl, man will auch gar nicht so richtig informieren oder ich, also jedenfalls nicht zu viele Details, weil Datenschutz und sie wissen schon.
Ja und zu viele Informationen könnten die Öffentlichkeit ja nur verunsichern. So, ne? Und ich,
denke äh das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Also zu wenig Informationen tragen jetzt hier eigentlich zur Vorunsicherung bei und vor allem es äh es ist ja auch.
Meine Wärme parallel noch diese Auseinandersetzung mit den Zweiflern. Ne.
Und man man will den Zweiflern eigentlich immer gerne so entgegenstehen und sagen, so komm, mach mal halb lang, äh hier.
Ist die Lage, wie sie sich tatsächlich abspielt. So und deine Großverschwörungen, die du jetzt hier gerade in der Hosentasche zusammen äh knölst.
Die kann nicht stimmen, weil und dann kann man natürlich ein Stück weit auch argumentieren, weil grundsätzlich denke ich, man gibt's einfach keinerlei Anlass für irgendeine Großverschwörung, aber es gibt halt einfach eine große Verpeilung. Und diese Großverpeilung.
Äh wirkt sich halt genauso desinformierend aus. Ne, sodass man da schnell sagen kann, na ja, das ist ja hier alles Absicht, wo am Ende vielleicht einfach auch nur.
Weiß ich nicht, gepaart mit Unwilligkeit oder eben diese diesen schlich
eintrainierten Verhältnis, wie man eben die Öffentlichkeit letzten Endes unterrichten sollte oder vielleicht auch so ein elitäres
so eine elitäre Grundhaltung mit, das versteht ihr ja sowieso nicht und wenn man jetzt hier irgendwie die ganzen Details äh rauspacken, dann dann ja, glaubt mal, unseren Aussagen, wir haben uns das mal schon angeschaut, das passt schon. So das, das ist eigentlich so das, was.
Das ist. Oft in vielen Dingen vielleicht auch richtig, ja? Also es gibt Sachverhalt, die sind tatsächlich so schwierig zu erklären
dass dass man sich da eher noch selber das eigene Grabschau füllt, wenn man dann zu viele Details rausbringt. Nur wir reden ja jetzt hier auch wirklich über einen anderen
eine andere Schnittstelle, ja? Also gerade dieser offene Brief, der ist ja jetzt nicht von irgendwelchen Leuten geschrieben worden, sondern er ist von Datenjournalisten geschrieben, von Leuten, die können
programmieren, die kennen sich irgendwie in Stochastik und in in Statistik äh
aus oder sind zumindest bereit, sich das notwendige Wissen auch überzuhelfen oder mit anderen Leuten zusammenzuarbeiten, die das haben. Oder eben wie du das jetzt auch die ganze Zeit gemacht hast, einfach selber reinnörden, mal schauen, was äh äh geht durch die Daten
durchschauen, solange bis man es verstanden hat. Und da ist natürlich
viel Schmerz mit dabei und irgendwo natürlich dann auch damit verbunden so eine gewisse Demotivation. Obwohl man hier eigentlich an der Stelle so eine zweite Front schaffen könnte
die sagen kann so, ja, wir haben uns das mal genauer angeschaut.
Über die ähnliche Diskussion, wenn wir jetzt eh gleich nochmal im Bezug auf die App äh kommen, ne. Äh wir haben uns das mal angeschaut, passt schon.
So, also es ist so, ne, wir haben, wir haben genug Daten, das zu beurteilen.
Ja oder eben äh hier, was ist denn das hier? Guckt euch doch äh das nochmal
an oder dass es irgendwie so optimal, wie das berichtet wird, das führt eher in die Irre, so weil sowas wäre hier auch äh ständig machen, wie gesagt, diese ganzen Einflussfaktoren. Ich habe aber auch noch.
Eine leicht andere These oder Erklärung äh äh vielleicht, was da vor sich geht. Wir haben ja gesagt, das ist für uns alle die erste Pandinie. Jetzt hatte man sich dann plötzlich eingestellt auf.
Diese Situation auf, ich sage mal, die Phase zwei, die Hochphase der Pandemie, aber,
äh wir sind halt jetzt in einer neuen Phase. So. Und äh diese neue Phase, die braucht halt auch eine
andere Kommunikation, also nicht nur, also nicht nur andere Maßnahmen jetzt, die wir, die wir brauchen, um uns zu schützen, sondern halt auch das ganze geschehen, da muss man halt jetzt bisschen aus einer anderen Perspektive draufgucken und.
Anders kommunizieren eigentlich mit der Öffentlichkeit, ja? Und diese Dynamik da sind unsere Behörden nicht gut.
Drin äh sich halt ständig immer wieder aufs Neue anzupassen, sozusagen, jeden Monat eigentlich eine neue Strategie äh zu entwickeln und äh auch,
Ja, dann neue Erkenntnisse zu kommunizieren. Wenn man da auch sagen muss, da
wenn dann plötzlich neue Erkenntnisse kommen und man schlauer ist, dann äh müsste halt auch die Presse und Öffentlichkeit verstehen
äh dass man's halt vielleicht vorher von einem Monat oder vor zwei Monaten halt noch nicht genau gewusst hat. Und jetzt halt besser weiß, ja.
Da hat man sich die Befürchtung, das geht dann mit Vertrauensverlust einher, okay vor einem Monat was anderes erzählt. Jetzt erzählt ihr uns das. Wie sollen wir euch denn jetzt glauben, wenn das, was sie euch,
uns vor zwei Monaten ähm erzählt habt, so nicht stimmt, aber,
die Wahrheit ist halt jetzt auch nicht nicht so schwarz oder weiß, so. Und es ist ja nicht so, dass da kompletter Unsinn erzählt worden. Ich meine gut, das Thema mit den Masken.
Äh kommt da immer wieder hochkontrovers nach dem Motto ihr habt sonst so lange erzählt, dass Masken eher nichts bringen und jetzt auf einmal sind Masken,
ganz, ganz toll, wobei zumindest in den USA hat der gesagt, na ja
eigentlich um ehrlich zu sein, haben wir das mit den Masken deswegen nicht empfohlen, weil wir Angst hatten, wenn wir das tun, dass dann die Leute, die sie wirk,
dringend brauchen keine mehr haben. Was Herr damals eigentlich auch schon irgendwie durchgesickert ist und offensichtlich war, dass das
natürlich, dass das Thema da reinspielt. Das ist einfach zu wenig Masken für alle da sind. Und man deswegen keine Masken empfehlen kann,
so dass das dahinter.
Gut, so so richtig sauber gelaufen, ist das natürlich nicht. Also das da muss man sagen, wenn das tatsächlich so war und das, ich denke, das war so dann, ja, war das auch eigentlich ein bisschen eine leichte Täuschung.
Ja und äh wer wir einmal lügt, ne? Also das, das ist so ein bisschen das das Problem und wahrscheinlich hat man's einfach nicht für Möglichkeiten mal äh da die eigentliche Wahrheit auszusprechen,
ja, nämlich zu sagen, wir gehen schon davon aus, dass Masken helfen, wir müssen bloß jetzt die Masken priorisieren, ja.
Äh haltet euch mal noch ein bisschen zurück und wir arbeiten dran. Jetzt ist natürlich so, dass die Regierung teilweise eben auch das nicht auf die Kette bekommen haben. Da hatte Deutschland ja schon seine Schwierigkeiten und in Großbritannien ist es so richtig scheiße gelaufen in dieser Hinsicht, also sie haben ja da
sich auch, also verhoben.
Noch und Nöchersach bestellt, die dann am Ende überhaupt keine Qualität hatten. Klar, haben natürlich alle irgendwo einen China umgeklickt und versucht, irgendwas zu kriegen
haben das Tassbam bekommen mit ja hier oder Maske, da haben wir ganz viele Millionen und so bestillen überweise hier und dann kommt das schon irgendwann, dann haben sie halt so,
bekommen, der einfach nicht die Qualitätsanforderung gerecht geworden ist. So, ne, aber ich meine, da kann man dann auch auf die Dynamik der Gesellschaft setzen. Also es ist ganze Stoffmasken selber neben Dingen und so äh viele
Schneide rein und und und Textilhersteller, die ja ohnehin Verdienstausfälle hatten, haben sich ja auch relativ schnell drauf eingestellt, um was angeboten. Das hätte schon funktioniert, aber das
Ja, das wurde so einfach nicht genutzt.
Gut, ich gestehe sicherlich auch vielen Akteuren zu, dass damals die Studienlage tatsächlich so war, äh, dass man die Wirksamkeit von Masken,
in bestimmten Fällen so nicht wirklich belegen konnte, ja
So, also man konnte sich durchaus berechtigt auf den Standpunkt stellen, ist.
Ist nicht sicher, ob es hilft. So, wir können's nicht nachweisen, ob's hilft, auch so ein bisschen eine parallele zur Chorona-App äh jetzt. Jetzt hat sich aber gezeigt
bei den Ländern, die jetzt einfach gesagt haben, ist uns egal, ob wir glauben, dass es hilft oder nicht äh wir ordnen das jetzt einfach mal an, wie in Tschechien.
Ja, vor allem, ich meine, es gab eine relativ klare äh Faktenlage, dass es nicht schadet.
Also zumindest äh hilft es bei der Verbreitung. Ähm aber äh es ist natürlich, ich finde es nach wie vor, dass Maske tragen,
extrem unangenehm, so. Ich versuche das halt auch zu minimieren
was natürlich auch immer das Einkauferlebnis doch deutlich schmälert, wenn man da
mit der Maske rumrennt. So, gerade mal größere Mengen an Lebensmitteln, so Familieneinkauf, mit zwei Einkaufswagen und so unterwegs ist
und äh ja, da ist man doch schon froh, wenn man dann wieder draußen ist und die Maske abnehmen kann oder es ist natürlich auch ein Problem so jetzt für.
Immer Güter, die man nicht unbedingt braucht, also sagen, eher so, ja, Wellness, Shopping, sage ich mal, äh oder wohlwohlfühlshopping
es halt jetzt gerade auch nicht so angesagt und das sieht natürlich auch der Einzelhandel gerade, dass so die Kunden noch nicht zurück sind, ja?
Ja gut, also äh mein Twitter des Tages in dieser Hinsicht äh lautet wer eine Maske unangenehm findet, wird ein Beatmungsgerät hassen.
Ja
Also, ich sage, es wird wieder spannend. Wir hatten ja immer darüber spekuliert, wie lange wir diese Sendung freie noch aufrecht erhalten können. Jetzt ist es wieder so, wie so ein typischer Hollywoodfilm zieht jetzt gerade wieder die Spannungskurve an,
und äh ja, also ich denke, mindestens ein ist endlich.
Äh oder nicht nur, also wäre wahrscheinlich noch mehr als eine Sendung äh brauchen, bis das Ganze äh jetzt äh einen eindeutigen, uninteressanten Ausgang gefunden haben wird.
Gut, dann kommen wir nochmal zur Meldung der Woche, die Corona waren App, die wir hier nun ausführlichst äh vorerzählt haben, in gewisser Hinsicht. Also uns relativ viel Zeit.
Ähm gegönnt haben, die ganzen Abwägungen, der Systeme und die möglichen Auswirkungen auf Privatsphäre et cetera, die Machbarkeit und die Wirksamkeit
alles haben wir hier besprochen und es lief da dann irgendwann auf diesen Launch hinaus, der war jetzt am Dienstag.
Pressekonferenz mit äh allen Großkopf hatten der Beteiligten äh Organisationen und Firmen, die daran mitgewirkt haben und äh ja, irgendwann in der Nacht auf den Dienstag wurde die Software dann verfügbar und siehe da.
Stand heute lautet die offizielle Zahl neun Komma sechs Millionen Downloads der Apps auf beiden Plattformen.
Also insgesamt zusammengerechnet.
Dass es sehr ordentlich erstmal, also als als Staat äh denke ich, mein.
Mehr kann's immer werden, aber äh ja, also das ist,
vermutlich, ich habe jetzt keine genauen Vergleiche, aber ich würde mal sagen, dass es vermutlich schon so am gemessen am
Anteil der Bevölkerung wahrscheinlich der erfolgreichste Staat einer solchen.
Stehen es hier irgendwo auf der Welt gegeben hat.
Das weiß ich nicht, ob das auf der ganzen Welt so war, also.
In gut Europa. Europa können wir's kann man, glaube ich, relativ sicher äh sagen oder kennst du da irgendeine Konkurrenz-App äh äh sage ich.
Ja, was weiß ich hier so super, Mario und so, wo das irgendwie wochenlang vorher angekündigt wurde, da weiß ich jetzt nicht so ganz genau, wie da die Zahlen waren, aber sowas kann natürlich schon durchaus ein äh aber im Bereich Gesundheit
Oder eine eine App einer, einer einer Behörde äh bestimmt nicht.
Genau, der also da da wollte ich drauf hinaus. Also einer Corona waren App äh.
Ach so, in dieser Kategorie von.
In dieser Kategorie von.
Das auf jeden Fall.
Tracing Apps.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie erfolgreich die in Italien waren, da habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nichts gelesen, aber äh ich denke, das ist schon ganz äh eine ganz ordentliche Zahl. Und man kann sich natürlich fragen, warum eigentlich?
Ja ähm ich denke mal äh so, dass es ja unsere,
nicht nur unsere Einschätzung, dass da halt eine Menge richtig gemacht wurde ausnahmsweise. So, das hat mir auch, dass das Thema, dass
sagen so wie die Entwicklung gelaufen ist, offen und dass man sich für das dezentrale Modell entschieden hat, das hat.
Bei vielen Leuten nicht bei allen, doch äh denke ich, auch eine Menge Bedenken äh ausgeräumt.
Obwohl es ist natürlich auch die Leute gibt, die sagen, oh Gott, Stasi-App.
Ja, wir werden jetzt überwacht äh alle Überwacht, genau.
Genau. Und dann das sofort auf WhatsApp und Facebook erstmal verbrei.
Genau und oft füttern, ja. Ja.
Ja gut, dass man die die hast du ja immer, ne? Aber ich sage, Mama, es gibt, glaube ich, eine ganze Menge Leute dazwischen. Und das ist so ein bisschen äh was man in der Politik immer so gerne als die Mitte.
Bezeichnet. Ne? Also du hast halt Leute, die sich intensiv damit beschäftigen, die haben dann irgendwie eine relativ klare Meinung oder Leute, die äh aus irgendwelchen anderen Gründen,
einfach das ganze Thema, jetzt vielleicht nicht ganz so intensiv, wie wir, aber doch relativ aufmerksam begleiten, dass du jetzt nicht irgendwie das erste Mal gehört haben, dass es sowas
schon auch eine gewisse Antizipation. Davon hatten und sich mindestens gesagt haben, äh so angucken, kann ich mir das auf jeden Fall mal. Mal gucken, ob mein Telefon explodiert.
Und dann hast du natürlich an den anderen Rändern natürlich diese ganzen Extremisten aller Art,
Leute, die das irgendwie aus grundsätzlichen Erwägungen nicht gut finden, die es technisch nicht einschätzen
können, denen man irgendwie noch nie was hat sagen können, bis hin halt zu diesen extremen äh äh Schworplanen und Aluhüten, den äh offensichtlich eh kaum noch zu helfen ist. Aber dazwischen hast du
wahrscheinlich neunzig Prozent der Bevölkerung
die einfach entweder noch nie was davon gehört haben oder sich halt einfach so auf die allgemeine Meinung, wie sie sich denn eben so entwickelt äh hören, ja, äh Medienberichte vielleicht auch einfach nur
nehmen und dann war's natürlich hilfreich, dass so die gesamt mediale Posaune eigentlich eher in diese Richtung getutet hat mit ja.
Kann man mal ausprobieren. So und das hat er schon gereicht. Und das, ja, das ist auf jeden Fall einen Erfolg und ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen.
Vorstellen heißt nicht, dass ich sie unbedingt damit rechne, aber es könnte mir vorstellen, dass das dann auch in der Politik.
Äh mal entsprechend wohlwollend zur Kenntnis genommen wird und sie sich nicht jetzt einfach nur.
Äh den Erfolg jetzt äh ans Reverheften und sagen wir.
Ist doch super gelaufen. So, ja, aber nicht gleich mitdenken, so, warum eigentlich?
Ja, sondern einfach nur glauben, dass dass dass das wäre sozusagen ein ein Selbstverständnis gewesen. Das ist so gekommen.
Na ja, auf jeden Fall haben wir jetzt die Situation, dass äh knapp zehn Millionen Download stattgefunden haben. Was wir nicht wissen, ist.
Wie viele dieser Apps laufen jetzt auch.
Dieser Apps wurden explizit eingeschaltet, wie viele wurden nicht wieder ausgeschaltet und destalliert, wie viele äh haben technisch auch funktioniert, ja? Also wir haben ja jetzt auch noch keine Aussage dadrüber, wie gut das System funktioniert.
Klar, Kot war vorher da, Leute, habt sich das angeschaut, aber wir wissen immer Realld Installation, ist nochmal eine ganz andere Nummer. Da muss nur irgendein Bitte in die falsche Richtung geguckt haben und schon was weiß ich. Das lädt die App keine Daten runter oder.
Lädt sie runter und durch unten blöden Back testet sie nichts, also wissen wir nicht. Wenn wir alles in den nächsten Tagen feststellen, ich bin auch gespannt, ähm wann wir das erste Update sehen werden für diese Software, weil wird sicherlich was kommen.
Und dann wird man das alles erst beurteilen können. Wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist es auch so, also man kann jetzt auf 'n iPhone zumindest.
Ähm in den Settings gibt's so einen Eintrag.
Datenschutz und da gibt's dann wiederum den Eintrag Health, also Gesundheit und dort gibt's wiederum einen Eintrag für dieses neunzehn Kontaktprotokoll,
Da ist dann unter anderem aufgeführt, ob es denn derzeit eingeschaltet ist, welches die aktuell aktive App ist, die das eben entsprechend.
Konsumiert. Und dann gibt's wiederum noch einen Eintrag Kontaktüberprüfung. Und da ich jetzt vorher.
Mit der lettischen App Abtorikovid rumgespielt habe und auch der dieser Bitterversion, dieser private Version von dem Swiss Kovit.
Die hatten schon Schlüssel veröffentlicht und die wurden offensichtlich von den Apps runtergeladen und dann eben gegen dieses systemfreien Walk.
Ausgeführt und man sieht also in diesen Settings eine Liste von solchen Überprüfungen. Da ist also jeder Vorgang mit Datum und Uhrzeit.
Ähm markiert, wie viele Schlüssel da ähm,
abgeglichen wurden und so weiter. Welche App das gemacht hat und ja, da kann man halt schon mal sehen, wenn der Aktivität ist, dann kann ich die auch überprüfen, aber da hat jetzt die Corona-Bahn-App noch nichts hinzugefügt.
Also bei mir ja äh sehe ich auch, wenn ich das aufrufe und wie gesagt, in den allgemeinen Systems äh nicht in den Settings der App ähm so.
Ja ist bei mir erstmal auch nichts zu sehen, was.
Bedeutet, dass wohl auch bisher noch keinerlei Alarmmeldungen äh sich auf dem Server befinden. Das heißt, es hat bisher noch keine ähm sagen Warnung.
Gegeben. So oder kann bisher noch keine Warnung gegeben haben.
Nee, es ist. Also, es kann eine gegeben haben und durch irgendein Back wurde sie nicht heruntergeladen. Und das kann auch.
Mhm.
Ja. Äh wir wissen nur, dass es bisher noch keine vollständige Durchreichung gegeben hat. So, wo, was auch immer, ist der Grund dafür ist es, kann sein, dass es noch.
Noch niemanden gibt, der diese App ernebelt hatte und das Feature schon genutzt hat, weil er dann genau an dem Tag sein Test bekommen, aber wir reden ja jetzt über einen Zeitraum von zwei Tagen. Das heißt, die allermeisten Leute.
Haben das Ding frühestens Dienstag überhaupt erst runtergeladen.
Und dann müssen sie im Prinzip zu dem Zeitpunkt an dem Tag auch schon Test gemacht haben und den das Ergebnis erhalten haben, damit
da überhaupt irgendwas da ist. Und äh vierundzwanzig Stunden muss das Ding sowieso erstmal laufen, bevor man eigentlich raushauen kann, weil man kann ihn nicht an dem Tag selber raushauen. Also frühestens Mittwoch
wir haben jetzt Freitag, also es gab jetzt maximal achtundvierzig Stunden Zeit. Also das müssen wir in der Woche nochmal sehen.
Ja, also es kann eigentlich auch noch nichts gekommen sein. Es ist völlig völlig richtig. Wobei, was du,
auch schon mal gesagt hattest, man hätte ja schon vielleicht einen
paar Meldungen hinterlegen können von Telefonen äh oder Synthetische Meldungen oder Meldungen von Telefonen, die äh keine,
Kontakte äh wirklich mit echten äh äh Telefon hatten. Also hätte irgendwie vielleicht fünf oder zehn Telefone untereinander ein bisschen äh spielen äh äh lassen können und äh dann halt,
ja entsprechend Meldungen losschicken und sehen, ob da dann was passiert. Vielleicht,
machen, die Leute das neu, also ich würde jedenfalls tun. Also ich würde halt auch da ja die Datengewinnung und das testen alles so ein bisschen schwierig ist wegen
Privatsphäre, weil man ja nicht auf die Geräte draufgucken kann und nicht weiß, was da passiert, könnten aber oder sollten aber.
Die Leute, die das betreiben, eben entsprechende Tests äh fahren.
Einem isolierten Gerätekreis, wo sie dann testen können.
Da verstehe ich ja nicht so ganz genau, warum das jetzt nicht äh gemacht wurde. Also es ist mir tatsächlich.
Ja, hätte auch noch einen weiteren Vorteil so aus privatsphäre Gründen.
Weil wenn ich jetzt sage der erst bin, der da jetzt Datenökmitte, dann äh,
funktioniert das mit dem durchmischen, mit den Daten anderer natürlich auch nicht so gut. Ist jetzt zwar nicht schlimm. So aber es wäre halt schöner, wenn da vorher schon bisschen oder wenn ein bisschen was drauf wäre, sozusagen Covertraffic, wie man das
nennt wäre jetzt nicht verkehrt.
Aber es ist äh gab durchaus interessante ähm Ergebnisse, es sind zum Beispiel ein paar Leute mit äh Bluetooth Scannern, mal durch eine Stadt gelaufen, das war in dem Fall die Bochumer Innenstadt.
Die sind einfach mal ein paar Stunden äh mit diesem Scanner durch die Gegend geradelt, haben sie also einfach da Fußgängerzonenbereich, weiß ich ganz genau, äh irgendwie in der City
rumgedrückt und einfach mal eingesammelt. Man kann ja jetzt diese Beakons auch mit nicht
Telefon einsammeln, dann sieht man halt diese ganzen Random IDs und wie hier schon mehrfach erklärt, man kann die halt niemanden zuordnen, aber man sieht halt, wo.
Sind denn welche? Und dann haben die halt quasi die GPS-Location einfach noch mit äh aufgezeichnet und so eine kleine gemacht und äh
ja, stellt sich raus, dass also das äh tatsächlich schon ganz interessante äh.
Ergebnisse nach sich äh gezogen hat. Also sie haben innerhalb einer Stunde eintausendeinhundert Identity-Feier aufgezeichnet.
Ne, also klar, tausendeinhundert Adentiffire heißt nicht tausendeinhundert Telefone, sondern das kann auch sein, dass man da ein
Telefon zweimal gesehen hat und äh nur eben zwei verschiedene
gehabt hat, aber wenn man eine Stunde unterwegs war, ist die also mindestens ein Viertel. Davon ist es auf jeden Fall. Also da haben sie minde
zweihundertfünfzig gesehen, wahrscheinlich waren's aber auch wirklich mehr Telefone. Weil dann weil weil die Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Dass man jetzt, wenn man durch die Stadt radelt.
Sehr oft jetzt immer wieder an den selben Telefonen vorbeikommen. Die ist ja schon relativ gering. Also ich würde mal sagen gefühlt so.
Achthundertneunhundert verschiedene Telefone dürfen da gesehen sein. Und das ist äh gestern gewesen, also am Donnerstag das ist ähm.
Schon ganz ordentlich, indem man einfach mal nur so irgendeine Innenstadt genommen hat.
Ja, mir juckt es ja auch schon bisschen in den Fingern, äh mir äh so eine App äh zusammenzuhacken
wo ich halt äh ja mir die Biekens anzeigen lassen kann, äh die in der Umgebung sind. Wenn jetzt ab jetzt keine Ahnung.
Jetzt Apple äh oder Google, irgendwelche technischen Maßnahmen getroffen haben, äh die es einer normalen App.
Unterbinden genau diese Art von auch sagen mit einer normalen App zu empfangen.
Äh hm ist nicht so.
Nee, also du kannst ja, es gibt so Bluetooth, ist genau die kannst du auch aufm iPhone äh runterladen, damit habe ich schon mal rumexperimentiert und ähm die, ja, die haben jetzt noch keinen expliziten Support für diesen Typ.
Aber man man kann diese Pickniens einfach sehen. Das ist jetzt wirklich.
Okay. Ah, wollen wir mal gu.
Nicht im Hintergrund, ne? Klar, das ist.
Ja ja, nee, nee, schon.
Aber so im Vordergrund kann's halt einfach starten, kannst du scannen, dann siehst du Dinge auch. Ich habe das mal so neben mein Telefon äh gehalten und ähm habe dann immer so Kontaktprotokoll ausgeschaltet, wieder eingeschaltet und dann
Sofort war ein anderes Beaken äh da, also eine andere ID. Und nach fünfzehn Minuten hat sie sich halt auch geändert. Also das,
hat schon im Wesentlichen so funktioniert, wie das äh beschrieben wurde und von daher ist das eigentlich ein relativ
guter Test, also das das hatte ich jetzt gar nicht so mit gerechnet, aber die Idee war relativ gut, ne.
Ah, okay, dann muss ich, muss ich mal gucken.
Also die haben hier verwendet auf äh Android, äh eine äh App, die heißt Ramble, Bluetooth LE, Mepper und die kann wohl direkt, da kann man direkt sagen, hier äh Service, Filter.
Und zeichnet dann sozusagen.
Aus, ne? Sie schreiben auch ja klar, es kann sein, dass ein Nutzer mit mehreren aufgezeichnet wurde, aber deswegen sind wir die ganze Zeit in Bewegung geblieben, es war sonnig, in Bochum, Innenstadt war gut besucht und ja, dann eben tausendeinhundert.
Dinger äh wie zu erwarten, auf beliebten Einkaufsstraßen, großen Plätzen findet man auch die meisten Nutzer.
Ah ja und genau und sie schreiben noch in unserem Experiment, konnten wir meist zehn bis fünfzehn Smartphones in unserer Nähe erkennen. Und das nur vierundzwanzig Stunden nach Einführung. Also stehst irgendwo.
Und vierundzwanzig Stunden, nachdem diese App gelauncht ist, kannst du irgendwo in der Bochumer Innenstadt stehen und siehst gleichzeitig zehn Verschiedener. Das ist schon, das ist schon ganz gut.
Das klingt nice.
Ja, was machen wir da jetzt draus? Es gab natürlich auch noch andere.
Sichtweisen dadrauf, also als das Lounge äh rückte vor allem am Montag
prasselt es sehr viele Berichte, also man hat schon gesehen, alle haben sich schon ein bisschen äh warm gemacht für diesen Launch-Day und es gab natürlich auch.
Ähm eine ganze Menge Zweifler und wurden dann auch sehr viele Security ähm bezogene, Privatsphäre bezogene Analysen wieder durchgereicht, die teilweise schon länger bekannt waren.
Unter anderem eine Darmstädter Studie.
Die äh hatte ich gesehen, aber dann war ich äh zu beschäftigt, um mit dir in Ruhe anzuschauen, aber du hast die dir mal angeguckt.
Ja, genau, weil ich dachte, oh interessant, da hat sich äh jemand nochmal die Sicherheit angeguckt und so.
Wurde das in der Presse zumindest kommuniziert, dass äh sagen sie erfolgreich
Angriffe durchgeführt hätten jetzt auf die Chorona Warm-App,
und ja das hat mich natürlich,
interessiert äh so, was die da jetzt zustande gebracht haben und ja, ich war dann äh sehr schnell, also hier wie je weiter ich in der Studie gekommen bin, umso
ja gibt's ein deutsches Wort für also.
Begeistert. Ähm so wenig.
Und unterbegeistert oder unter euphorisch oder wie auch immer war ich dann, weil äh tatsächlich dann sich feststellte war, dass,
ja
Das da war eigentlich nicht wirklich was, beziehungsweise waren zwei Dinge, um das jetzt mal kurz vielleicht zu beleuchten. Sie hatten da.
So zwei Angriffsszenarien demonstriert, einmal ein
Angriff auf die Privatsphäre eines Nutzers, wo sie meinten sie seien in der Lage, mit Hilfe von Trekkingstationen, dann den Aufenthaltsort oder des Bewegungsmuster
äh von jemandem zu ermitteln, der sich mit so einem Gerät durch die Gegend bewegt hat. Und.
Da halt drauf zu schauen. Ich meine, das erfordert halt dieser Angriff äh.
Flächendeckend Sensoren, die man ausbringt. So, um das zu tun, aber selbst dann, äh wenn man das tun äh könnte und wir müssen verdammt viele Sensoren sein, also für für Berlin.
Äh werden's.
Zwischen einhunderttausend und dreihunderttausend Sensoren, je nachdem, ob man, wie wir alle fünfzig Meter in der Fläche oder nur entlang der Straßen welche ausbringt, so. Also bräuchte halt absurd viele, aber.
Also mit Sensoren meinst du Bluetooth-Empfänger. Also einfach Geräte, die einfach Bluetooth empfangen und äh in irgendeiner Form in der Lage sind, diese Informationen äh was sie da empfangen haben, auch weiterzuleiten. Also ins Internet angeschlossen sind.
Genau, also im Prinzip, sage ich mal,
abgespeckte Handys, äh wenn man so will, ohne Display und Tastatur, aber wir müssen natürlich schon irgendwie mit Strom versorgt werden und irgendwie die Daten dann auch abliefern, äh so. Also.
Ja in meine nehmen Payper haben sie halt zwölf
äh solcher ähm Sensoren oder Stationen dort ausgebracht und haben dann aber erstmal auch festgestellt, okay, wir können mit dem ganzen Zahlensalat erstmal nichts anfangen,
den wir empfangen. Erst, wenn jetzt ein Nutzer ähm.
Seine Daten freigibt, also sagt, ich bin infiziert worden und möchte gerne andere warnen. Dann waren sie in der Lage, so ein paar.
Von den wieder zu finden. So,
und zu sagen, okay der war dann jetzt zu dem und dem Zeitpunkt offenbar.
Äh äh dort. So, das ist aber eigentlich auch der.
Ganze Sinn und Zweck des Systems, ja, festzustellen, wenn ich Leute warne
äh dass diejenigen, die dann meine Bietensempfang haben, feststellen können, dass sie in Kontakt mit mir getreten sind. Also eigentlich so eine, ja, was ich dann frag, gut, was und was genau
wolltet ihr jetzt damit zeigen, ja? So, also.
Äh ja, also sowohl sagt nicht wirklich praktikabel als als Angriff und letztlich eigentlich nur äh die Funktion des Systems demonstriert und gezeigt, dass ähm auch die,
Kies solange
man nichts frei gibt, man auch gar nichts damit anfangen kann. Also sie waren nicht in der Lage irgendwie die sonst zu zuordnen.
Genau, weil er keiner kann eine weitere Mieterdaten dran sind. Also man man weiß zwar.
Ein Telefon, ja, einer Person, die sich infiziert gemeldet hat, in den letzten vierzehn Tagen war an diesem Ort an diesem Zeitpunkt.
So und das ist die vollständige Information.
Die man bekommt. So, man kann das ganze nur mit weiterem Aufwand in irgendeiner Form auf eine Person menschen.
So, genau, also der sagen, also der erste.
Sogenannte Angriff, äh äh denen sie dort gefahren haben
so hat sich dann so eigentlich für mich in Wohlgefallen aufgelöst, weil der mehr oder weniger nur die ordnungsgemäße bestimmungsgemäße Funktion des Systems demonstriert hat, ja
so
Das Zweite war ein Angriff jetzt auf die integrität des Systems, indem man versucht hat Fehlalarme.
Auszulösen. Ein sogenannte oder Wurmlochangriff, wie ich das genannt habe, der im Prinzip so funktioniert, man hat halt ein.
Empfänger, der halt jetzt bietens empfängt an irgendeinem belebten Platz. Man schickt diese Bietens dann über das Internet zu einem anderen Gerät und sendet die an anderer Stelle,
aus. Und ähm jetzt
hatten sie halt gesagt, ja und wir könnten jetzt irgendwie äh Leute gezielt damit in Quarantäne schicken und das Vertrauen in das System erschüttern und sozusagen
Angriffe auf unsere Gesundheitsinfrastruktur fahren, weil äh wir generieren dann so viele Fehlalarme damit
dass äh alle sich plötzlich testen lassen und in garantäne sind und ganz furchtbar. Ja.
Dazu muss man sagen, so ja.
Das funktioniert, ja, allerdings auch so in Rieltheim und ähm tatsächlich kann man jetzt nicht einfach irgendwelche IDs einsammeln und die,
permanent die ganze Zeit wieder verwenden, sondern eben auch maximal nur diese fünfzehn Minuten, ne? Weil danach würden die von den Telefonen als äh ungültig erkannt werden. Aber im Prinzip funktioniert
man kann in der Bochumer Innenstadt sozusagen da diese ganzen Beakons aufsaugen und in die äh in Berlin in irgendeiner Innenstadt deiner Wahl äh auch wieder rauslassen.
Genau, zehn Minuten lang jedenfalls. So, theoretisch. Ja, äh, geht das,
alles. So und das war im wesentlichen auch, was sie gemacht haben. Sie haben das halt implementiert und gezeigt, so, allerdings muss man erstmal dazu sagen, sie haben jetzt nicht.
Das echte Ding benutzt dafür, sondern sie haben das irgendwie nachgebaut, also zu sagen, dann analog davon. So, haben versucht, es ist natürlich so.
Ähnlich wie möglich auch zu implementieren, aber äh ja äh muss man erstmal festhalten,
was immer sie implementiert haben
wird sich erstmal nicht hundertprozentig wie die Corona Warm-App oder sogar äh diese ja Google Apple äh die wurde halt nicht benutzt. Das heißt, es war jetzt nicht.
Erstmal ein Angriff direkt auf das System, sondern auf ein Nachbau des Systems so, wo man erstmal schon sagen muss, okay.
Der aber genauso funktioniert.
Ja, der, der, äh, ich sage mal, genauso funktioniert, theoretisch, grundsätzlich, aber es sind jetzt zwei.
Probleme, worin halt deren App sich halt äh,
potenziell von der App unterscheidet äh die sie da sagen angegriffen äh äh haben. Weil
um jetzt diesen Angriff erfolgreich durchzuführen, um um jetzt irgendwas zu bewirken in dem in dem System, muss ich ja
dann bieten von jemandem einsammeln, der dann in den nächsten vierzehn Tagen an Kurve erkrankt und sich,
testen lässt, weil ansonsten nützt mir dieser Bieten nicht, sonst habe ich halt die verbreitet von Leuten, die aber nie nennen, Alarm,
auslösen, ja? So die nie ihre äh äh ihre Daten verschicken. Das heißt, es kommt da auch zu, keinerlei Match,
sei es von den Bietens, die ich einsammle, sind ist der Großteil einfach komplett nutzlos, der bewirkt noch nicht mal, dass da mehr Daten auf den Servern sind, weil die Leute ja ihre Daten gar nicht hochladen.
Ja, das heißt, da werden bisschen paar mehr Daten auf den Telefon gesammelt, von den Leuten und haben halt.
Nicht wirklich irgendeine Wirkung. So und damit ich aber jetzt äh sagen mit einer gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Jemanden dabeihabe, muss ich.
Bei derzeitiger infizierten Verteilung oder bei derzeitiger Infektionsrate,
größtenordnungsmäßig zehntausend verschiedene Beats einsammeln, ja,
oder mit einer dabei ist äh wahrscheinlich nicht sicher, aber mit einer guten Wahrscheinlichkeit, äh der dann irgendwann mal,
krank wird, ja? Und seine und eine Warnung verschickt so. Das alleine ist aber schon mal, wenn man das durchrechnet, wenn jetzt jeder dritte.
Die App hat, habe ich dann gerechnet, bräuchte man also eine Menschenmenge von dreißigtausend Leuten, äh die ich abhöre äh und in zehn Minuten halt äh dort.
Diese Bietensabgreife. Problem ist ähm selbst in Berlin findest du nicht mal am Alex
zur Rush Hour gehen da in zehn oder fünfzehn Minuten dreißigtausend Leute durch. Ganz abgesehen davon vom
dann den funktechnischen Problem
Diese bieten's überhaupt einzusammeln. Also man kann ja erstmal feststellen, so viele Bietens, wie ich brauche, kriege ich erstmal gar nicht eingesammelt. So, aber das ist noch der einfachere Part, wenn ich die Bietens jetzt aussende
dann muss sich auch die kompletten zehntausend Beatens irgendwie auf die Geräte der Opfer draufkriegen
ja? Das dürfte aber noch schwieriger oder noch unmöglicher sein, weil.
Ja das Telefon nur alle paar Minuten für einen Paar Sekunden auf Empfang geh.
Alle fünf Minuten, ja.
Ja so, also alle also in der Speck steht, sagen spätestens alle fünf Minuten oder wenn's zwischendurch der Prozessor sowieso aufgewacht ist, dann kann er das gleich miterledigen.
Äh okay, also wenn man gerade irgendwie das Ding einschaltet, äh irgendwas anderes macht, dann dann nutze einfach diese Zeit, ne? Genau.
Ja oder eine oder eine Kurznachricht reinkommt oder irgendeinen irgendeine irgendeine Message oder so und der.
Also wahrscheinlich hören sie schon öfter zu, aber es kann im schlimmsten Fall sein, wenn das Ding einfach keine Nachrichten bekommt, einfach in der Handtasche liegt. Das ist irgendwie die ersten fünf Minuten für ein paar Sekunden zuhört.
Genau äh und das ist einfach aus Energiespargründen, weil das senden ist super billig.
Das machen die Chips von alleine, also das wirkt sich auch nicht großartig aus, aber das Empfang ist halt teuer, weil da der Prozessor die Daten entgegennehmen und verarbeiten und wegspeichern muss und das alles ist.
Vergleichsweise Energie intensiv voranhalten, auch die ganzen anderen.
Bisherigen Bluetooths, Apps, gescheitert sind, dass sie halt die Batterie extrem leer gesorgt haben, so.
Wenn ich also diesen Wurmlochangriff durchführe, dann sende ich halt den Großteil meiner Biekens, an Geräte, die gerade gar nicht auf empfangen sind.
Ja
und die gehen dann halt kurzzeitig eben für ein paar Sekunden auf Empfang und können dann äh so wie es aussieht, etwa hundertfünfzig Bietens pro Sekunde entgegennehmen. So, damit kriege ich natürlich auch,
bei Weiben nicht meine zehntausend Beatens
äh durch und ähm so dann habe ich vielleicht noch eine zweite Chance, da kriege ich dann auch nochmal ein paar vielleicht durch und dann sind die schon wieder ungültig geworden, ja. Das heißt.
In der Praxis äh halte ich diesen Angriff einfach für nicht durchführbar.
Also zumindest nicht mit einem einzigen Outfit. Man könnte natürlich jetzt argumentieren, wenn ich das jetzt aber an fünfhundert Stellen mache, ja, dann sieht's schon wieder ganz anders aus.
Na ja, selbst dann nicht, weil ich weiß ja nicht, äh sagen, ich äh allein beim Empfang, ich weiß ja nicht, von den, ich muss ja diese
Endlos viele bieten's erstmal einsammeln und wieder aussenden und ich und selbst wenn ich das skaliere äh so, das ändert,
nichts so richtig äh dran, aber ja, klar, äh ja.
Ähm also an dieser Wahrscheinlichkeit ändert sich nichts, dass ich halt irgendwie zehntausend Bietens einsammeln und
äh weiterleiten und dann aber äh auf das andere Gerät äh bringen muss. So und beides erscheint mir äh einfach extrem,
unwahrscheinlich. Also meine Einschätzung war das im besten Fall, wenn man wirklich viel Geld investiert und sich viel Mühe gibt und ein bisschen Glück hat, dass man vielleicht eine Handvoll an Fehlalarmen
äh pro Woche damit produzieren könnt, ja? Und auf der anderen Seite testen wir aber ähm pro Woche,
dreihunderttausend negative Nichtpatienten oder Verdächtige oder wie auch immer so,
Ja. Also mit die Nil of Serviceangriff auf unser Gesundheitssystem oder irgendwie
keine Ahnung, unnötige Tests zu verursachen oder so. Ja, bei neunundneunzig Prozent negativen Tests, äh die wir im Moment machen, ja? Es ist einfach nur lächerlich, so.
Sagt grundsätzlich.
Äh sagen, was sie gemacht haben, sich das anzugucken und auch äh diese das zu implementieren und so. Äh ehrlich gesagt.
Super.
Wunderbar, wenn nicht dieser Teil lang Schlüsse oder ja, diese Einordnung. Also, wenn sie denen weggelassen hätten, so hätte ich applaudiert und gedankt.
Aber wie sie das Ding einfach aufgeblasen haben, also diese Schlüsse, die sie dann daraus gezogen haben, nämlich, dass man äh real.
Die Corona Worn-App angreifen könnte oder sie die erfolgreich angegriffen hätten, dass entwertet einfach,
deren komplette Arbeit oder die vielleicht nicht komplett, sondern sie haben halt ein paar Sachen bestätigt, auch weil gesagt, ja
bei zentralen Apps, die gehen halt gar nicht, da haben sich auch ganz klar positioniert, die kann man halt komplett in die Tonne kloppen, würde ich ihnen
auch bei Pflichten und dieser technisch, was sie gemacht haben, ja, kann man so machen, aber.
Man erreicht nicht den Zweck äh damit
den sie behaupten, äh dass man erreicht und äh sie haben, finde ich, äh damit auch allen einen Beerendienst erwiesen
so wurde dann den den Journalisten jetzt vorgeworfen äh so, die FAZ hatte dann den Artikel veröffentlicht, wenn man den liest, klingt das alles total seriös, Wissenschaftler aus Rhein-Main haben eine Schwachstelle im Sicherheitssystem der Corona Tracing Apps
äh gefunden und so und ja Wissenschaftler und Professoren und das Klang alles super seriös, aber offensichtlich,
hat sich, hat halt wer auch immer das geschrieben hat, sich nicht die Mühe gemacht.
Sich äh das Paper einfach mal kritisch äh durchzulesen oder vielleicht mal eine zweite oder dritte Meinung äh einzuholen an an der Stelle
und äh das hat eben schon dann auch bei Leuten zur Verunsicherung geführt, weil das bleibt halt haften. Ja?
Ja, also die sind ja dann auch irgendwie noch dabei, noch ein eigenes Protokoll zu entwerfen. Bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, wie viel.
Äh Erfolg, dass äh tatsächlich haben kann, aber das basiert meines Wissens auch dadrauf, dass dann wirklich ein widerektionaler Austausch zwischen diesen Telefonen stattfindet und das äh hat ja dann gleich wieder dasselbe Problem mit dem erhöhten Kommunikationsaufwand,
besondere, wenn man jetzt einen größeren Menschengruppen sind, weil wir dann auf einmal ganz viele Telefone sind und alle sollen mit allen irgendwie gleichzeitig telefonieren, also nicht telefonieren, aber halt irgendwie die Regionaldaten austauschen, dann muss halt sehr viel Empfang äh werden sehr viel Protokollaufwand gibt
trieben werden, dann wird's äh teuer.
Ja, also vielleicht grundsätzlich äh dazu äh äh tatsächlich.
An dem Corona Warm-App Protokoll, was gewählt wurde,
wurde etwas gemacht, was auch bei anderen Systemen, wie bei Magnetkarten oder wie bei GSM, Mobiltelefonen oder bei auf früheren Chipkarten äh und so gemacht wurde, dass,
dass nicht beide Seiten gegenseitig sich
authentifizieren. So, das ist immer ein Einfallstor für eben solche Replayattacken oder Tunnelattacken oder also die Möglichkeit, zu sagen
ja, Daten aufzuzeichnen und dann später äh wieder abzuspielen und äh damit das System anzugreifen. Insofern
ja, hätte man lieber, wenn beide Gegenstellen sich versichern, wer sie sind.
Und da haben tatsächlich einige der Leute, die da auch dieses.
SicherheitspayPer geschrieben haben, haben auch einen eigenen Vorschlag oder eine eigene.
Tracing-App entwickelt, die eben mit solchen KontaktIDs arbeiten, wo dann.
Ein Schlüsselaustausch stattfindet, wo ich dann statt eines bieten, so die erste Hälfte eines Schlüssels.
Aussende des dann von der anderen Seite unterschrieben wird und wieder zurückgeschickt wird und sogenannter,
und dann kann man sich wirklich sicher sein. Problem ist nur, äh wie du schon richtig gesagt hattest, daskaliert einfach nicht. So, das äh führt dann wieder dazu, dass die Batterie leer gesaugt wird
und dass wenn mehr als dieser Mazehn bis,
dreißig Leute auf einem Haufen stehen, einfach dieses System zusammenbricht, ja? Während.
Ich mal überschlagen habe.
Dass die Corona One-App, also der Google Apple Standard, das technisch ähm mehrere tausend Leute sich irgendwie klumpen könnten, bevor es da.
Probleme mit der Bandbreite äh gibt an der Stelle und nichts mehr durchkommt, ja.
Also so ein realistisches Szenario für zum Beispiel so äh Konzerte. Großes Publikum auf Engenraum und so.
Ja. Also die Parameter von der von diesem Google, Apple, Corona One, App,
System der Technologie sind so gewählt, dass man wahrscheinlich auch in größeren kompakten Menschenmengen noch vernünftige Ergebnisse,
äh bekommen.
Ja und die Last für meine Batterie auch unabhängig dafür davon ist, wie viele Leute jetzt in meiner Umgebung sind. Es spielt halt einfach keine Rolle. Ob da jetzt.
Keine Ahnung. Drei oder dreihundert Leute äh gerade neben mir stehen, das hat kaum Unterschied auf äh,
den den Stromverbrauch während eben dieses Kontakt ID-Protokoll stehst du dann mit Leuten zusammen und dann sagt er das halt einfach
deinen Akku leer. Und das ist für mich so ein Killerkriterium und hat aus meiner Sicht äh hat man halt bei dem Protokoll schon einen ganz guten Kompromiss,
gefunden, so es ist jetzt nicht die perfekte äh hundertzwölf Prozent äh Sicherheit,
so, aber es ist halt mehr als gut genug eigentlich aus meiner Sicht so, also ich habe da tatsächlich keinerlei Bedenken im Gegensatz zu gehe ich allen anderen. Also wenn man.
Irgendwie sich.
Unwohl fühlt, dann man als erstes äh einfach auf kompletten das Smartphone verzichten oder müsste sich ein speziell.
Ausgerüstetes oder oder gibt gepatchtes Smartphone nehmen, was halt,
nicht navigieren kann, äh wo man eigentlich auch keinen Web raus drauf hat äh und äh vielleicht E-Mails schicken und empfangen kann so, das wäre wahrscheinlich noch eine unkritische Funktion. Vorausgesetzt mal betreibt seinen eigenen E-Mail-Server, aber das kann man halt machen
aber ansonsten alles andere, was ich irgendwie mit dem Telefon mache, fast jede App, die ich benutze, äh wenn ich ins Web gehe
wenn ich gesagt, navigiere mir den Ort angucke, dann gebe ich halt äh einfach so viel mehr kritische Daten.
Preis, als dass die Corona äh Warn-App tut.
Ja und selbst äh selbst wenn man jetzt den Start als solchen, ja? Ich meine, das ist ja auch so ein Argument, was man immer so hört oder so, Schlagzeile, viel mehr, so ja, der Start will uns jetzt alle aus äh Horchen und jetzt haben wir hier so ein, ein Sniffing und Beobachtungstool und so weiter, ne?
Also wenn der Staat.
Wirklich das jetzt wollen würde, ja? Dann hat er diese.
Möglichkeit bereits seit den neunziger Jahren heißt Mobilfunknetz.
Und in dem Moment, wo ich mit so einem Telefon rumlaufe, bin ich mit meiner Telefonnummer eingebucht in so einem Mobilfunknetz.
Man weiß immer genau, wo man gerade ist.
Und das ist, das ist ja auch eine permanente Debatte, rund um Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Abfrage von diesem Mobilfunk.
Das
das sind das sind genau diese Schlachtfelder, die seit Jahren und Jahrzehnten mit äh zwischen Datenschützern und äh der Legislative dort ähm Polizei auch natürlich äh gefochten wird. Nur
dieses Protokoll hier,
mit diesem Zweck, das ist einfach nicht der Ort, wo das stattfindet. Und man kann's nicht oft genug betonen. Das einzige, wirklich offene Loch ist eben dieser Punkt mit
wenn ich dann meine Schüssel freigehe, wenn ich selber das.
Entscheide, das zu tun, dann erst gibt es diese Einblicke, die eigentlich gar keine Einblicke sind. Wenn man damit ein Problem hat.
Dann macht man das einfach nicht. Würde ich zwar nicht zu raten, aber äh diese Möglichkeit besteht und ansonsten ist da einfach überhaupt nichts zu h.
Das,
das muss jeder mit sich selbst dann ausmachen, wie er das sozusagen ethisch findet, weil man kann halt die App auch einfach parasitär nutzen, sage ich mal, ich man schleppt sie einfach mit sich rum und lässt sich halt warnen
aber wenn man dann selber erkrankt, warnt man halt andere nicht. So.
Selbst wenn man irgendwie zweifel hat, ob man das möchte, äh so ist es immer noch so, solange man nicht erkrankt und.
Sich ohnehin bei Gesundheitsabmeldet und dort seine Daten und Namen und äh Adressen und Telefonnummern aller Kontaktpersonen äh sowieso schon hinterlassen hat
ja? Die einem einfallen, wenn man dann noch der Meinung ist, so, man möchte jetzt.
Aber nicht irgendwie offenbaren, mit wem man jetzt in den letzten vierzehn Tagen wirklich in Kontakt gewesen, weil man kann ja auch beim Gesundheitsamtes verschweigen, so bestimmte Kontakte.
Ja, niemand zwingt einem diesen Knopf zu drücken und äh seine Daten rauszuschicken, die kann ich dann immer noch ich kann die jederzeit löschen.
Kannst mir jederzeit anders überlegen, aber äh sie.
Wenn ich sie installiere, habe ich erstmal einfach eine Warnfunktion für mich.
Und gebe keine Datenpreis. Ansonsten, ja, das kann man vielleicht so schon mal festhalten, das heißt.
Selbst irgendwelche paranoiden äh egoistischen Aluhüte hätten kein.
Grund jetzt erstmal nicht, sich zumindest die App zu installieren und zu betreiben.
Ja was was die Aluhüte betrifft, muss man auch nochmal kurz sagen.
Und dann sollen wir vielleicht mal dieses Paper auch wieder verlassen ähm was halt hier auch noch mit aufkommt ist so dieses na ja eine die Anonymisierung ist aber möglich ja, man kann ja doch herausfinden wie diese Person sind.
Wenn man halt parallel noch Kameras aufbaut mit Gesichtserkennung.
Genau, das war das war übrigens auch in den PayPal so, wo ich, wo ich auch nur dachte, relativ weit
am Anfang, wo ich auch noch dachte, oh nee, jetzt nicht schon wieder so ein, so ein so ein Hollywood äh äh plott, so, weil man sich dann fragt, okay, wenn ich eine Datenbank habe, wo
alle,
Leute mit ihren Bildern sowieso schon drinstehen und ich Kameras aufhängen kann äh mit denen ich Leute identifizieren kann, dann kann ich die halt auch treten. Ja, also das ist ist.
Dann brauchen wir die Elbe dann auch nicht mehr dafür. Ich meine, dann dann ist man ihr sowieso schon dabei. So, dann macht meine Gesichtserkennung, dann weiß man ja auch, dass sie da sind. Also sind dann dann hat man ja im Prinzip schon alles.
Genau, dann braucht man den ganzen Bluetooth Quatsch nicht mehr.
Kommen wir vielleicht mal zu ein paar anderen äh Fragen. Was ist noch nicht erwähnt hatten, was über viele hier wahrscheinlich ohnehin schon mitbekommen haben. Ich hatte ja die Gelegenheit mit.
Zwei Entwicklern aus dem SAP-Entwicklungsteam von der zu sprechen. Das ist hier OK.
Sendung Nummer dreißig. Ich äh vermute jetzt einfach mal alle, die hier jetzt reinhören, haben das wahrscheinlich auch schon gehört, weil.
Die Sendung war ganz gut nachgefragt. Das ging dann äh doch ganz gut rum, dass es äh jetzt auf jeden Fall äh mein neuer Download-Rekord hierbei bei UKW.
Ähm du hast auch gehört, oder?
Ja ja, ich hab's komplett von Anfang.
Bis Ende gehört, weil ich fand's halt auf mehreren Ebenen total interessant, äh so die Sendung. Erstmal natürlich so am Anfang ähm sagen so ein bisschen Annäherung äh so, also es war ja halt.
Schon, also man merkte schon, am Anfang, dass sie so ein bisschen unsicher waren, die beiden, was können sie jetzt eigentlich sagen und was nicht so, weil sie sind ja auch interner und die ganze Presse guckt da drauf und es ist halt schon auch politisch Heikel und so und
am Anfang waren sie so ein bisschen, glaube ich erstmal nicht ganz sicher oder äh ja, aber so je.
Länger die Sendung lief, um so flutschiger, lief das äh ganze auch und umso entspannter wurden sie, glaube ich
auch und haben dann halt äh ja unglaublich viele interessante Sachen
dort erzählt, wie das gelaufen ist, eigentlich der Hintergrund der Entwicklung und welche Gedanken sie sich einfach gemacht haben und so, auch welcher Geist dort eigentlich vorherrschte und wie viel Mühe sie sich
anstellen, dann gegeben haben, wo man das jetzt erstmal gar nicht so offensichtlich vermuten würde und auch wie viele.
Probleme, ähm sie gestoßen sind, die sie dann umschiffen mussten, um tatsächlich die Privatsphäre äh zu erhalten. Das war, also das war
schon interessant und kann ich nur sagen, also jeden, der vielleicht.
Corona App, Angst, vielleicht so wie Flugangst äh so, also könnte diese Sendung vielleicht auch so ein bisschen so einen Heilmittel gegen Corona-App Angst äh sein.
Weil man so ein bisschen äh ja mit den äh sagen mit den Ingenieuren, die das Flugzeug gebaut haben,
die, die mit zusammen einem im im Flugzeug fliegen und einem erklären, welche Gedanken sie sich alle gemacht haben und welchen Aufwand sie getrieben haben, damit das Flugzeug jetzt nicht abstürzt. So, so würde ich.
So würde ich das sagen und,
Äh das hat für mich auch noch andere Aspekte oder einen, vor allem einen anderen Aspekt beleuchtet, den ich so noch so gar nicht auf dem Schirm hatte,
nämlich, dass die App ja nicht nur alleine eine Corona One-App ist, äh sondern dass als Bonus, die Meldung von Testergebnissen äh auch noch über die App.
Möglich,
ist, beziehungsweise sein wird, muss man äh sagen, aber grundsätzlich äh ist das Feature, glaube ich, ist schon drin, so, aber äh.
Genau, es ist fehlt jetzt einfach noch an den Anbindungen an die Labora, wie viele Labore jetzt tatsächlich schon angebunden sind. Darüber gibt's sehr unterschiedliche Aussagen. Sie ähm mal also,
mit Sicherheit ist es erst die die Minderheit. So, also ich habe irgendwas von von null bis zwanzig Prozent gehört, wo da jetzt gerade die Wahrheit liegt, kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Ja, aber auf jeden Fall,
Ist dieses, sage mal, bisher nicht so sehr beachtete Feature äh möglicherweise für sich allein genommen schon einen Gamechanger
und zwar aus folgendem Grund. Also oder vielleicht sollten wir erstmal sagen äh so was das Feature genau macht oder wie das abläuft, magst du das erzählen oder.
Meine, ich hatte, ich hatte es auch schon, als wir die ersten Pläne gesehen haben, hat die hier das auch schon erwähnt. Vielleicht ist ja das einfach in dem Moment nicht so bewusst gewesen, so, ne? Aber äh tatsächlich äh
ist die Grundidee ja, die in dem Moment, wo man sich also zu einem, so einen Termin bekommen für einen Test.
Ob das jetzt beim Hausarzt ist oder in so einem speziellen Testzentrum
ähm dann bekommt man ja ohnehin so einen Bogen, wo man alle möglichen Angaben machen muss. Und äh
diese Bögen haben also diese Tests haben schon eigene IDs und nicht nur nicht nur die Test haben wie ich jetzt auch in der Sendung erst erfahren habe sondern jedes einzelne Wattestäbchen, was dir äh in die Nase geschoben wird, hat eine einzelne IT,
Und.
Wie heißt dieser Begleitschein noch äh Probenbegleitschein, glaube ich. Mhm.
Genau. Und das äh, wenn man ein bisschen drüber nachdenkt, macht ja auch alles total Sinn, weil hier geht's wirklich um eine sehr genaue Erfassung. Man muss da sehr viele Fehler möglichst verhindern, da ist es natürlich.
Total wichtig, dass man alles ordentlich zuordnen kann. Also es gibt auch diese ID schon. Im Rahmen dieser ganzen Chorona Warnappentwicklung jetzt ist halt beschlossen worden, all diese Tests noch um eine weitere ID zu ergänzen.
Äh beziehungsweise meinen zweiten Code noch zu ergänzen
wo dann jetzt dieselbe oder eine andere ID noch mit drin kodiert ist, die auf jeden Fall dafür gedacht ist, eben nicht nur diesen ganzen Data Flow innerhalb des Medizinischen Systems.
Äh zu organisieren, ne? Weil das da geht's ja dann vor allem um Labore, Ärzte, et cetera und alle übertragen und äh,
Unternehmen und so weiter. Die solche IDs benutzen äh können und vermutlich auch schon benutzen, sondern dass eben neu jetzt eben dieses, wir möchten jetzt eben den eigentlichen Probanden, also diejenige Person, die eben getestet wird,
auch direkt digital davon in Kenntnis setzen von diesem Ergebnis. Und dafür wird halt diese ID mit reingenommen. Und die kann man dann halt in dem Moment, wo man
bitte am Telefon dahin geht, kann man die eben schon sofort einscannen. Und wenn man das getan hat, merkt sich das Telefon, also das Telefon meldet sich dann sozusagen sofort an bei dem Server und sagt, ja hör mal.
Ich sitze jetzt hier gerade vor diesem Test, mit dem werde ich jetzt getestet. Ich möchte mich jetzt sofort für eine Ergebnisübermittlung registrieren.
Und in dem Moment, wo das getan ist, ist diese Nummer sozusagen auch schon verbrannt, da kann niemand anderes sich mehr dafür registrieren und äh ja, dann wartet man eigentlich nur noch und die Abfragt halt regelmäßig nach
sag mal, wie sieht's denn aus? Gibt's da jetzt schon ein Ergebnis? Und wenn's das Ergebnis gibt, dann kriegt man halt die Rückmeldung, ja, hier Ergebnisse da ist, positiv ist negativ und so weiter.
Ja. Und man muss dann vielleicht auch noch auch noch ergänzen äh dass
die Benachrichtigung nicht über Google oder Apple Server
läuft, also nicht wie der übliche Benachrichtigungsmechanismus und man kriegt auch nicht sofort das Ergebnis
sondern man kriegt halt nur eine Nachricht, Pop auf, wie du gesagt hast, ein Ergebnis liegt vor, so
wie gesagt, so schön, dass falls man gerade in der Cafeteria sitzt, äh möchte man halt nicht äh dass da vielleicht auf dem Handy jetzt äh hochkommt. Ah, du bist im Übrigen jetzt gerade positiv getestet
äh warten. So.
Also, du kannst es, du kannst es nicht an der Notification sehen, aber du kannst es dann schon in der App sehen.
Ja, du musst dann in die App reingehen und äh kannst dir dann das Ergebnis.
Anzeigen lassen. Es wird dann aber auch nicht auf dem Gerät gespeichert, äh sondern es wird dann nur direkt live abgeholt, wird.
Angezeigt und wenn du die App wieder zumachst, ist es auch nicht auf dem Gerät gespeichert, so dass falls dir irgendwie dein Handy abhanden kommen sollte, ist das auch nicht äh gut, wobei, ja, die A.
Nein, du hast dann schon, ich weiß nicht, ganz genau, was du da jetzt mitbekommen hast, aber äh.
Du bekommst ja dann angeboten dann eben deine Schlüssel aufzuteilen. Also wenn dann dieser Schritt äh vorbei ist, dann sieht man vielleicht davon nichts mehr
aber äh man würde in dem Moment des der App schon ansehen, weil sie ja, dass er sozusagen anbietet, jetzt diese Schlüsselübermittlung zu machen. Wie lange die dann da noch liegt und ob man da sofort reagieren muss, das weiß ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht, das habe ich auch nicht hinterfragt.
Nee, aber äh was was sie, was ich mich erinnere, was sie halt gesagt haben ist. Das Testergebnis selbst wird nicht auf dem Gerät dann gespeichert.
So eine Frage, die dann auch,
auf Twitter an mich rangetragen wurde, ist ja äh aber so, ich ich wohne halt über einer Kneipe
und da sitzen halt immer ganz, ganz viele Leute unten so fünf Meter von mir entfernt und äh muss ich denn jetzt damit rechnen, dann ständig Alarme zu kriegen, weil da unten irgendwelche infizierten Gesessen haben.
Mit denen ich aber gar nichts zu tun hatte.
Und wie sicher kann ich denn aber überhaupt sein, dass ich denn eigentlich eine Warnung kriege, also funktioniert das Ding? Dann bietet mir das denn irgendwie äh einen Schutz, das ist sozusagen die Frage nach den vollstpositiv oder voll,
Negatives äh so an der Stelle und wenn man dann darüber nachdenkt, ist die eigentliche Frage.
So die, die auch noch dahinter steckt, was bedeutet denn jetzt, wenn ich so eine Warnung bekomme,
so unter welchen Bedingungen bekomme ich äh sie. So und.
Erstmal kann man sagen, da ja die Signalstärke auch mit eingeht und die Dauer,
ist es so gut, wenn die Leute sitzen, da unten sicherlich länger, sodass zumindest die Dauer dieses Kriterium könnte erfüllt sein. Das Gerät wird sehr wahrscheinlich auf die Entfernung auch eine Menge der.
Bieten's empfangen von den Leuten
die da unten sitzen, aber ich gehe davon aus, dass bei fünf Meter Abstand in den allerseltensten Fällen äh das Nähekriterium hinreichend erfüllt
sein wird, was da auch noch mit reinkommen. So, das ist der eine Punkt.
Und der andere Punkt äh auch es hat mir vorhin ja schon sozusagen wahrscheinlich müssen da so zehntausend Leute
äh im äh Laufe des Essen schon verdammt großes Lokal, wo die Leute sehr eng sitzen sein, damit überhaupt die, also die Wahrscheinlichkeit einer Warnung ist grundsätzlich auch äh äh sehr, sehr,
gering. So, das kann man erstmal festhalten, dass also
es jetzt nicht auszuschließen ist, äh dass vielleicht durch Reflexionen oder wie auch immer irgendeinen Defektes gerät, was äh stärker sendet als alle anderen Geräte
ist da äh vielleicht auch zu einer versehentlichen Nähe, Identifikation kommt, aber in Verbindung mit der geringen
Anzahl auch der Infizierten ist es wahrscheinlich eher dann wie ein Lottogewinn, sodass beide Bedingungen zutreffen, also äh ich kann mir beim besten Willen nicht vorstellen, dass es da in nenswerten Umfang
äh zu Fehlalarmen aufgrund einer solchen Situation. Jetzt kommt. Die andere Frage ist, okay, was.
Bedeutet es, denn jetzt, wenn ich so eine Warnung bekomme äh und was sagt denn jetzt eigentlich die App.
Dazu, was die offiziellen Handlungsanweisungen und die offiziellen Handlungsanweisungen sind.
Klär das bitte mit Arzt oder Gesundheitsamt ab, was.
Du jetzt im Einzelnen machen sollst, die dann Fragen äh stellen werden und die,
andere Sache ist, es ist jetzt kein auch kein Ersatz für seinen gesunden Menschenverstand oder nochmal eine eine Einschätzung
in welcher Situation man sich denn jetzt tatsächlich befunden hat und
viele Alarme könnten dann auch wahrscheinlich kommen von Personen, die im selben Haushalt leben, von denen man ohnehin schon dann weiß, weil die einem das wahrscheinlich schon vorher erzählen werden, bevor sie dann die Warnung ab,
äh schicken werden. Man hat man's schon aus anderer Quelle erfahren. Also,
es ist jetzt nicht so, dass wenn die App jetzt warnt, äh man jetzt in Panik verfallen muss, äh dass man infiziert ist, weil auch das ist dann wiederum die die Wahrscheinlichkei.
Dass man infiziert ist
wenn so eine Warnung kommt, dürfte unter ein Prozent liegen, weit unter ein Prozent, weil wir wissen, dass ja im Testregime, wo jetzt ja Leute getestet werden, die,
Symptome und Kontakt haben oder zumindest nachgewiesen Kontakt schon hatten. Aus dieser Gruppe,
so sind nur ein Prozent positiv. So, das heißt, wenn ich also eine Warnung äh Kriege und mich dann testen lasse,
und auch keine Symptome habe, dann bin ich zu neunundneunzig Komma neun
Prozent auch negativ. Es gibt da natürlich ein gewisses Restrisiko und das will man dann auch auch erfassen und äh ja, aber.
Wie gesagt, wenn so ein positives Ergebnis auf dem Telefon kommt, gibt es erstmal keinerlei Grund äh zur Panik. Kann man vielleicht erstmal festhalten. Und wenn man keine Symptome hat, schon gar nicht.
Die andere Sache jetzt mit dem Volksnegativ, da muss man,
ganz klar sagen, das Ding ist jetzt kein Virusdetektor so, wo das Ding angeht, so nach dem Motto, Achtung, Corona Gefahr.
Äh so, sondern es ist halt einfach nur einen weiterer äh Pfeiler, also es schützt
nicht vor Ansteckung des des, das Handy und es warnt auch nicht vor Ansteckung und es ist auch kein Ersatz für Mundschutz oder andere Sicherheitsmaßnahmen oder Abstand, sondern
es ist halt äh eher etwas, äh was mir eigentlich potentiell helfen kann,
schneller eine Behandlung zu kriegen und was insbesondere helfen kann.
Bei diesem schnellen Virus, der ja nur so eine super kurze Generationszeit hat, bei.
Dieser Art von Virus, einen Zeitvorsprung zu kriegen. Und das waren noch so ein Punkt, weswegen ich meinte, warum.
Das ein Gamechanger sein kann, allein dieses äh Test zurückmelden Feature
bei dieser kurzen Generationszeit ist Geschwindigkeit des ein- und alles um die Ausbreitung zu stoppen und jede Stunde.
Die ich früher warnen kann und früher mich in Selbstquarantäne begebe und erstmal niemanden anstecke.
Das kann halt schon mal einen riesen Unterschied sein und die App äh für diejenigen, die sich dann entscheiden.
Die Warnung dann digital zu bekommen über das Gerät. Kann man sagen, dass man einen Zeitvorsprung von ein bis zwei Tagen.
Da rausholen kann. Und mittlerweile sind ja auch einige Gesundheitsämter ganz gut auf Zack oder sogar die meisten. Es ist also,
deutlich schneller geworden mit dem mit dem Melden im Vergleich zum zu Anfang der,
Panemie in den meisten Fällen und diese ein, zwei Tage können tatsächlich der entscheidende Gewinn sein und.
Ja in in zwar vielleicht ganz, ganz wenigen seltenen Fällen, aber in denen einfach viel schlimmes verhindern. So und dann,
Da könntest du mal.
Wollen wir auch sagen, okay, wie viel Prozent der Leute müssen jetzt eigentlich die App haben, damit es wie wirksam wird. Mal sagen, es würde ja schon reichen, wenn.
Die App mit ihren beiden funktionalitäten.
Den berühmten Reproduktionsfaktor von eins Komma null eins auf null Komma null neun neun senkt,
Ja, also mariginal, dann äh kann das äh schon der sagen, Entscheidungstreffer sein, also das, was den Unterschied zwischen Wachstum,
und Rückgang macht, der Effekt.
Ist tatsächlich relativ klein, den wir erzielen müssen. Wir haben ja am Anfang auch schon gesagt, dass unser R so eher immer um die null Komma.
Acht null Komma neun jetzt bei eins rumpendelt und solange es unter eins halten ist alles gut. Und wenn die uns eben nur hilft.
Ein ganz kleines Stückchen, aber eben dieses kleine Stückchen, dass wir unter eins bleiben, dann hat sich das Ding schon hundert mal bezahlt gemacht.
Ja, was so angesprochen hast, mit der äh Wirksamkeit, dieser App, da gab's ja ähm auch eine Studie aus ähm Oxford, war das, glaube ich.
Genau. Äh die mehrfach.
Direkt aber vor allem habe ich so den Eindruck auch so indirekt äh zitiert wurde, weil da kommt irgendwie diese Nummer mit diesen sechzig Prozent raus und ich weiß, dass wir auch darüber gesprochen haben, ich bin mir bloß gar nicht so sicher, obwohl ich hatte, glaube ich, diese Studie zu dem Zeitpunkt noch gar nicht bewusst gelesen.
Und äh das ist tatsächlich so ein Rissetsch, der gemacht wurde, explizit über die potenzielle.
Ähm wirksamkeit solcher Apps
jetzt keine Studie, die irgendwelche Apps schon untersucht hat, weil die gab's ja nicht, sondern es war sozusagen so eine hypothetische Studie, die gesagt hat, okay, wir modellieren das jetzt hier einfach mal
was das denn äh unter diesen ganzen Rahmenbedingungen, wie du sie jetzt auch gerade geschildert hast, also ne Beschleunigung, Verbreitungen, Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es irgendwie ein Treffer äh gibt, et cetera. Was, was müsste denn sozusagen vorhanden sein? Und
dann haben sie es halt einfach mal hochgerechnet und da kommt dann eben diese Zahl mit den sechzig Prozent her.
Allerdings war das jetzt nicht die Kernaussage dieser Studie. Ja, weil so wurde sie so ein bisschen zitiert. Ja, sechzig Prozent müssten da irgendwie alle installiert haben.
Äh dann wirkt das. So mit dem Umkehrschluss wenn es neunundfünfzig Prozent oder weniger sind, dann bringt das irgendwie alles gar nichts.
Und das, das äh ist etwas, was dann auch nochmal von den Autoren
aufgebracht wurde und nochmal so einen schönen Artikel dazu gibt, der das nochmal so auseinander nimmt und wir haben halt gesagt, na ja, äh klar, das mit den sechzig Prozent, das haben wir auch gesagt, aber erstens habt ihr nicht genau zugehört
was wir gesagt haben und ihr habt uns irgendwie auch nicht zu Ende zugehört, ne? Also erstmal,
war das die Aussage, wenn sechzig Prozent der Bevölkerung über so eine App verfügen.
Dann könnte sie halt diese Epidemie komplett stoppen. Also nur diese App,
unabhängig von von ganzen anderen Sachen, weil einfach so viel gewarnt werden würde, ja immer natürlich auch vorausgesetzt, dass diese ganzen Messmethoden greifen, et cetera, das sind alles,
annahm, ne? Aber sie sagen halt auch dazu, aber auch mit niedrigeren äh Zahlen von äh Abnutzung, kann
hier schon eine Reduktion von Fällen und Todesfällen stattfinden.
Und äh dass wenn das irgendwie so bis achtzig Prozent,
hochgeht, dass dann sozusagen allein allein die App oder andere Maßnahmen schon irgendwie hier äh greifen kann, also wenn achtzig Prozent aller Smartphone-User das machen.
Dann würde sich eben so ungefähr auf fünfundsechzig äh sechsundfünfzig bis sechzig Prozent aller Leute, also der Bevölkerung sozusagen äh runterrechnen lassen,
Ja, das besteht ich eigentlich auch nur noch, was wir hier eigentlich auch von Anfang an,
äh selber eingeschätzt haben. Das das ist sozusagen einfach ein Beitrag, es ist fügt dem, was wir ohnehin schon haben und was eben mal mehr und mal weniger gut funktioniert, etwas hinzu, wie gut dieses andere System.
Also wie gut das normale Contact Tracing, der Gesundheitsämter an sich funktioniert und vor allem, wie gut es jetzt diesen zusätzlichen Zulauf auch annimmt, das muss man dann.
Abwarten. Ne, weil das ist ja dann sozusagen auch ein Umkehrer. Normalerweise die haben halt einen Fall und dann rufen sie alle an. Das ist sozusagen der Arbeitsmodus, wie er jetzt ist.
Wir wissen dann sozusagen immer schon, was sie von diesen Leuten wollen, weil sie wissen, woher sie diese Information haben. Neu ist jetzt, das hält sich auf einmal Leute melden, die so aus dem Nichts und natürlich muss man auch sagen,
ohne einen Zusammenhang mit einem konkreten Fall sich melden.
Ja, also ist ja nicht so, dass einer anruft, sagst du, hier, äh, übrigens, ich bin die, die bisher noch vollkommen unbekannte äh Person im Fall X.
Ja? Und ich ich war da auch, wo du da gerade am Recherchieren bist. So ist ja nicht, sondern die Person kommt einfach nur an und sagt, ja, ich.
Ich habe hier Risiko gemeldet bekommen, ich melde mich einfach mal, kannst mich irgendwie einsortieren und dann wird's halt ein bisschen knifflig, weil welche Informationen hat denn diese Person? Äh eigentlich nur diese Information, na ja, ich war halt.
Irgendwo an einem Tag wohl von irgendjemand irgendwo in der Nähe und das kann halt im Zug gewesen sein, et cetera. Also das
Das bringt an der Stelle fehlt nicht so, das bringt eigentlich nur was. Wenn die Leute sagen, na ja, okay, meine Risikoeinschätzung ist besser mal testen lassen. Ich lasse mich mal testen,
Und da gibt's auch noch eine gute Zusatzinformation, nämlich die Tatsache, dass einfach es jetzt auch so ist, dass wenn man
von der App gesagt bekommt hohes Risiko, dass man dann eben auch seinen Test auch äh normalerweise bekommen sollte. Also es ist bei den Krankenkassen jetzt auch so drin und die Schweizer werden das auch so halten. Da muss man mal gucken, wie das angenommen wird.
Ja. Also die ist erstmal zu den sechzig Prozent äh.
Weil die Zeit haben ja auch irgendwie bekannt vor und dann habe ich mich erinnert, dass wir mal vor Wochen überschlagen hatten, äh was
denn so, also wie viel Leute denn wahrscheinlich so eine App
maximal nutzen würden oder oder könnten, so was denn so 'ne realistische Durchdringung unter optimalen Bedingungen.
Ist, wo man sagen kann, wow, äh also mehr war mehr ging eigentlich kaum und.
Ja, habe ich halt geguckt, gut, wir haben über neunzig
Prozent Smartphone Nutzung. Ich glaube sogar fünfundneunzig Prozent der Bevölkerung haben Smartphones und ungefähr,
achtzig Prozent haben Smartphones, die des theoretisch könnten und man kann natürlich nicht davon ausgehen, dass alle.
Deren Gerät das auch kann, dass installieren werden, weil es gibt Leute, die installieren einfach gar keine Apps oder wollen das aus Prinzip nicht. Das heißt, wenn man dann nochmal diese üblichen zwanzig Prozent.
Abzieht, dann kommt man halt auch ungefähr auf diese Größenordnung.
Sechzig Prozent der Bevölkerung und ich fand das jetzt lustig, dass halt dann eine Studie rauskommt, die halt dann äh mal wieder so eine Zahl bestätigt, wie man eben auf dem Bierdeckel äh ausgerechnet hatten von vor ein paar Wochen. Ähm,
Ja, also also ich habe die Studie tatsächlich selber jetzt jetzt gar nicht gar nicht gelesen und äh wenn,
das so wäre, wie die Studie das.
Da ermittelt hat oder oder vorhergesagt hat, dann äh äh wäre das schon hammermäßig. Ich meine.
Ich hab so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, dass man wirklich mit sechzig Prozent die App hätten, dass es alleine ausreichen würde, wobei man ja sagen muss, es ist ja dann nicht die App,
direkt von der der Schutz ausgeht, sondern die Tatsache, dass Leute, die dann eine Warnung erhalten,
äh sich dann umgehend in Quarantäne begeben und nicht nochmal einkaufen gehen oder halt nicht zu dem nächsten Business Meeting oder nicht nochmal in der Kneipe ihre potenziellen
äh Keime äh da.
Verteilen. Das ist ja dann das eigentliche, was was es verhindert und nicht das sagen nicht das Handy, sondern die Reaktion natürlich, wie sich die Leute dann verhalten, wenn sie eine Warnung
äh bekommen, dass es dann ja sagen, dass, was den den Virus bremst.
Und ja und das ist, ich meine, wird ja immer von Informationskrieg und so gesprochen und das ist halt schon Schuld, kann man sagen, bisschen Teil eines Informationskriegs gegen den Virus, wobei ich eigentlich diese Krieg,
das Rhetorik äh ein bisschen albern äh finde, die ja, weil die Amerikaner seit Jahrzehnten schon Krieg gegen alles Mögliche gegen das war, kein Krieg führen kann, aber.
Drogen und so, ja.
Kommen wir doch vielleicht mal auf ein äh weiteren Aspekt, der jetzt auch im Fokus gerät, nämlich die internationale Verbreitung dieses Modells.
Haben wir ja nur auch schon ein paar Mal drüber gesprochen, dass da hinter den Kulissen eine ganze Menge äh rotiert und ähm soweit ich das
aus dem Buschfunk herausgehört habe, verdichtet es sich jetzt auch, dass es hier so eine EU-Lösung geben wird und überhaupt haben wir in eine gewisse Dynamik,
die da auch noch dadurch angeheizt wird, dass wir verschiedene Länder, die ja ihren Sonderweg einfach weitergegangen sind, mittlerweile angekündigt haben oder ist auch schon durche Exekutiert haben, diesen Sonderweg nicht weiter,
gehen zu wollen.
Prominentes Beispiel ist ähm glaube ich äh Norwegen, da ist diese ganze App sogar von den Datenschützern einfach schlicht verboten worden. Die haben sich das angeschaut, haben gesagt, Leute, so geht's aber immer nicht
ja und man muss noch sagen, Norwegen ist ja noch nicht bei der EU, also da irgendwie auch selber drauf gekommen, da braucht es jetzt kein.
Eine DSGVO. Äh, bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, was jetzt ihre Kriterien waren, auf jeden Fall gab's dann die politische Entscheidung, okay, alles klar, wir stoppen das Ganze. Wir löschen alle Daten und wir äh werden dann auch mal.
Irgendwie was anderes machen und so, weil ich das mitbekommen habe, wollen sie dann auch auf das Dezentrale Modell setzen, ähnliche Nachricht gab's jetzt grade aus
Großbritannien, was mich ein bisschen gewundert hat, weil ich dachte, bei dem vertrottelten Zustand, indem sie gerade sind, äh dazu empfehle ich auch nochmal die letzte Sendung hier bei UKW, die aktuellen Stand rund um Brexit.
Äh dass dass sie da noch länger zu brauchen werden und noch länger so ein State of Dinal aufrechterhalten, obwohl ihre Krise gerade so krass ist. Die werden jetzt auch auf die zentrale Modell wechseln
ob sie da schon parallel, also es klang so ein bisschen durch, als ob sie parallel das sowieso schon mitentwickelt haben und jetzt nur sozusagen auf Option zwei setzen oder ob sie da nochmal komplett
froms Kretsch äh rangehen oder sich so vielleicht sogar den Deutschen äh holen, weiß ich alles nicht,
Tatsache ist, so wie es derzeit aussieht, gibt es halt entweder schon Apps, die Release sind oder deren Release zumindest unmittelbar bevorsteht in äh Lettland
Deutschland eben äh der Schweiz. Italien und äh in den Staatlichern,
ist äh Österreich, die ja ihre Stoppchorona App ändern, Belgien und Niederlande, im UK, Irland.
Estland, Spanien und Portugal, die alle auch irgendwie auf dieses dezentrale Modell wechseln.
Fehlt vor allem noch Frankreich,
dann wäre zumindest Westeuropa äh an der Stelle schon mal vereint, fehlt auch noch
Litauen, aber ich glaube, da ist äh das zentrale Modell auch aufgegeben worden und ich denke mal
die Balken werden da sowieso alle an einem Strang ziehen. Jetzt warte ich eigentlich nur noch darauf, dass dann das irgendwie auch mal in Finnland äh reinschweppt. Schweden könnte es eigentlich immer ganz gut gebrauchen, wenn man sich anschaut, wie viel Tote sie dor
haben und äh wie gesagt, die Norweger wollen halt auch noch ändern, Dänemark, äh Dänemark habe ich vergessen, Dänemark ist halt auch noch mit im Boot. Also, der Drops ist gelutscht und das geht halt auch so von der EU aus
es gibt da einfach einen zunehmenden Maße, die bestrebungen, das jetzt einfach mal so zum Standard zu erklären
und wenn ich's richtig einschätze, werden wir demnächst oder sover haben, also,
hatten wir ja schon hier diskutiert, kurz, also äh normalerweise hast du deine Clearings, kriegst du deine, deine kurz halt sozusagen von deiner deutschen
Also wir in Deutschland kriegen das so mit der Corona Warnapp in Deutschland, ja, weil meistens sind die Leute ja in einem Land.
Sagen wir mal ehrlich.
Wann ist zwar ab und zu mal im Ausland, aber meistens ist man's halt nicht. Und von daher funktioniert das ganz gut, aber eben für die Fälle, wo man eben woanders ist, kriegt man dann eben die Kies von einem anderen Server, wo die dann so zentral gesammelt werden.
Beziehungsweise es kann sogar sein, dass man einfach für die EU sagt, wir werfen das jetzt alles in einen Server rein und machen uns da überhaupt gar nicht großen Kopf rum, weil
kriegen wir dann irgendwie äh auch noch hin und dann äh haben wir das Ding zumindest auf einer europäischen Ebene schon mal gelöst und äh wie wir dann international weiter voranschreiten, werden wir dann halt in der nächsten Stufe sehen,
denke mal, auch bei äh Apple und Google durften sie sich dieses Problems bewusst sein und äh ich vermute mal, wir werden da relativ bald.
Neue Schritte sehen und neue Anpassungen und neue Ergänzungen zu diesem API. Ich denke mir jetzt, wo es einmal release ist, wenn sie sich den nächsten Schritt.
Auch sehr sorgfältig überlegen, ob das jetzt eine Sache von Wochen oder Monaten ist, kann ich gerade noch nicht so richtig einschätzen.
Ja, aber das klingt auch alles sehr erfreulich und auch.
Und sagen, fühlt sich irgendwie gut an, so in Deutschland mal Vorreiter auf der richtigen Seite äh ist so, es sind Zustand, den man eher selten hat und äh ja, also ich.
Finde das äh einfach gut, was da gerade passiert,
absehbar, eigentlich äh, dass das passieren würde, wobei, ja, war natürlich nie weiß,
so welche, ich meine, dass sie so viele irrsinnige Sachen passiert in der Krise und irrsinnige Entscheidungen in manchen Ländern.
Getroffen worden.
Sodass äh man da nie sicher sein kann, aber dieser Trend, der sich da mehr als abzeichnet, das finde ich sehr erfreulich.
Als die Corona-Warn-App gelauncht ist, da war ja der App Store ist dann nicht so schnell hinterher gezogen, was meiner Meinung nach vor allem da was damit zu tun hat, dass halt das Ding bei uns um null Uhr veröffentlicht wurde.
Und äh in den USA ist dann einfach noch eine Weile gedauert hat, bis die dann sozusagen.
Mal alles aktualisiert haben. Sprich, am Anfang war die App schwer zu finden, wenn man nach Corona gesucht hat oder so, kam alle möglichen Apps hoch, aber die nicht.
Das hat sich dann relativ schnell geändert und kurze Zeit später oder vielleicht war es auch gleich ein Moment ähm wurde dann diese App auch gefeaturet.
War dann auch relativ schnell natürlich die meistgeladene App.
Ist sie wahrscheinlich zu diesem Zeitpunkt. Immer noch, also die meistgeladene kostenlose App.
Und gibt da auch noch so eine so eine Apps, die wir gerade besonders toll finden, Kategorie, also ich beziehe mich jetzt auf den iOS App Store, kann ehrlich gesagt über Android äh keine Aussage machen, zeigt halt einfach nur, es hat eine Weile gedacht. Worauf ich eigentlich hinaus will, ist.
Es gibt halt auch noch andere Apps, die behaupten, sie würden jetzt hier irgendwie zur Lösung beitragen.
Ja, da gibt's also diverse Covit neunzehn hier, Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe, Apps. Was natürlich potenziell auch nochmal dazu beitragen kann und wenn man sich dann eben.
Gucke jetzt mal, ob ich jetzt in diesem Moment noch denselben Zustand ähm.
Vorfinde, den ich vor ein paar Tagen schon festgestellt habe, also ich gucke jetzt einfach mal kurz hier auf die Topkategorien.
Eine App Charts gratis. Aha, ich sehe, es hat sich ein bisschen verbessert. Okay, gut, weil äh am Anfang war es nämlich so, die Corona waren etwa auf Platz eins und auf Platz zwei Platz drei waren irgendwelche komischen anderen Kovet-Apps.
Vollkommen unklar, was sie überhaupt gemacht haben. Die meisten sind nur so Info-Apps mit unserer Symptomtrecker oder irgendwie sowas und das hat sich jetzt geändert mittlerweile ist äh Ikea wieder auf Platz zwei und WhatsApp auf Platz drei
Also irgendwas ist da auch äh getan worden. Es gibt also jetzt auf jeden Fall auch so eine Diskussion,
ob man denn nicht diese ganzen anderen Apps, diese ganzen Apps, die irgendwie nur von der anderen Apps abraten
man die nicht vielleicht sozusagen explizit mal ein bisschen runter tun sollte. Vielleicht geschieht das auch ähm.
Werden wir sehen. Ja.
Ja
War eigentlich schon am Ende unseres wöchentlichen Liedes. Haben wir noch irgendwelche Sachen.
Einzig, was wir noch noch ein, viel war, das Thema App-Zwang,
so, was ja dann auch ganz schnell dann ähm die Runde machte, so nach dem Motto, oh Gott, äh.
Ist ja alles ganz schön und gut, mit der Privatsphäre, aber jetzt äh fangen irgendwelche Leute schon an zu überlegen, so wird es wird man verpflichtet sein, diese App.
Zu installieren oder hört man irgendwie indirekt verpflichtet sein, diese App zu installieren, weil was weiß ich wirte oder bestimmte Veranstalter ein nicht reinlassen, wenn man die
App nicht am Laufen hat, aber äh ja, da
kann man auch nur sagen, das ist halt nicht kontrollierbar, es bringt auch nichts, äh sondern Zwang, so wie die App angelegt ist, weil äh ich äh meine Daten jederzeit löschen kann,
So, also ich kann der so tun, als hätte ich die App so vorzeigen und äh so, wenn ich rausgehe, drücke ich wieder auf den Löschen Knopf, so damit es also überhaupt gar nichts gewonnen, ja. Also
es ist schon mal unmöglich jemanden dazu zu.
Zwingen, also technisch unmöglich, ähm so dass ähm.
Zu tun, irgendwas da Preis zu geben oder sich treten zu lassen oder wie auch immer, deswegen,
ja äh halte ich das auch für ja aufgebauscht, diese Debatte hat zwar,
stattgefunden, so, aber ich denke, es haben sie auch genug Leute auch in der Politik klar dafür ausgesprochen, äh so das Ding wird freiwillig bleiben, äh so.
Es wird keinen Zwang geben und den gibt's auch an keiner Stelle, also es gibt kein Feature in dieser App auch was ich nutzen muss, ich muss.
Ihr muss selber an mehreren Stellen aktiv die Entscheidung treffen, ob ich was preisgeben will, euch die Daten senden will oder ob ich mein Ergebnis elektronisch haben will, so all diese Dinge oder ob ich wie ich nach einer erfolgten Warnung
dann darauf reagiere, all das, ja äh und es kann mir auch niemand nachweisen, dass ich gewarnt wurde. So.
Also all all die Dinge, also kann man sagen, äh ja, Zwang ist unmöglich und man sollte auch eigentlich.
Das Gerede darüber ähm ja äh Spekulationen darüber auch einfach mal einstellen, weil.
Was ist denn deine Einschätzung, wie erfolgreich das jetzt sein wird im Punkto Installationsverbreitung? War jetzt ganz unabhängig von was es uns am Ende bringen wird.
Gut, ich hatte sagen, so so spontan hatte ich.
Mit dreißig Prozent der Bevölkerung war so
ähm
also man muss da immer sagen, wann? So in einem Jahr oder in einem Monat äh und so sag mein absehbarer Zeit, also in einem Zeitraum von, ich sage mal, jetzt ein, zwei Monaten
oder so, wo
wenn das Ding dann angelaufen ist und man erste Erfahrungen damit gemacht hat und sich das nochmal rumspricht. Wahrscheinlich wird's dann noch so eine zweite Installationswelle.
Geben, wenn dann, sagen wir mal, erste Erfolgsmeldung kommen, kann ich mir gut vorstellen und äh ja, dass man dann am Ende.
Also die dreißig Prozent halte ich in absehbarer Zeit für realistisch und.
Ob man jetzt dann auf vierzig, fünfzig oder sechzig kommt, sehr schön, so.
Das wären vierundzwanzig Millionen Installationen. Wir haben jetzt schon neun Komma sechs nach drei Tagen.
Aber es geht am Anfang immer sehr schnell und.
Das ist mir ist mir bewusst, aber dass dass es sozusagen jetzt sehr frechholt, an dem wir äh äh sind und wir haben
sicherlich hier schon die erste Welle, aber es ist immer noch äh äh App, also ich vermute mal, das wird schon noch eine Weile dauern und nicht alle werden das jetzt auch immer sofort mitbekommen haben, aber es ist auch so ein bisschen talk aus der Town. Das ist schon mal
ganz gut. Also es gibt hier eine relativ gute Chance auf eine dreißig Prozent zu kommen. Ähm ich würde mal sagen, im ersten Monat.
Ja
Und dann wird relativ viel davon abhängen, ob wir Erfolgsmeldungen haben werden. Also, es braucht einfach jetzt diese Story, oh.
Ich habe eine Nachricht bekommen, mein Risiko wurde so oder so eingeschätzt.
Äh jetzt äh habe ich mich testen lassen und gucke mal da, ich war positiv und ich habe mich irgendwie sofort
zurückgehalten und bin nicht auf das äh Business Meeting und nicht in meine Lieblingsbar gegangen als diese Nachricht bekommen habe. Das, das ist sozusagen jetzt die Story, die ja eigentlich gebraucht wird.
Ja, wobei ich sagen muss, die Wahrscheinlichkeit ähm.
Dass das passiert, also es ist so, dass ich schätze, dass.
Ungefähr jeder tausendste Größenordnungsmäßig, der Gewarnt wird, äh, tatsächlich infiziert sein wird,
ja, weil wie gesagt, ist im Moment schon so, dass jeder Hund nur jeder hundertste, der im Moment sich testen lässt und wenn.
Ja, aber das ist ja keine, die sind ja nicht alles so freiwillige und und Kontakt verfolgte Personen, sondern in diesem ganzen Test sind ja auch diese ganzen regelmäßigen Tests mit drin.
Ja, die, die einfach turnusgemäß bei sonstigen Untersuchungen einfach mitgetestet werden.
Ja, mittlerweile schon gut wir wissen, leider auch wieder wäre schön, auch gehört auch zu den Daten, die wir eigentlich schon seit Wochen und Monaten einfordern, dass,
doch bitte auch irgendwie, wenn ein Test gemacht wird, dass halt dann doch auch die Ursachen, warum dieser Test gemacht wurde, mhm irgendwo mit veröffentlicht werden, zumindest statistisch gesagt wird,
Käse, so und so viel Prozent wurden gemacht, weil die Leute Symptome hatten, so und so viel Prozent
waren Wiederholung, Tests von Leuten, die in Behandlung sind, so und so viel Prozent fahren jetzt allgemeine Belegschaft,
Tests oder wurden gemacht, weil's halt Kontakte gab, aber wir haben halt all diese Zahlen nicht, deswegen ist das halt Spekulation. Meine Einschätzung ist es immer noch.
Der Großteil der Tests, der überwiegende Teil bei Leuten gemacht wird, die Symptome hatten und die potentiell Kontakt hatten.
Äh mindestens eins von beiden äh gegeben ist. So. Und ähm deswegen,
Ja, selbst wenn jetzt fünfzig oder hunderttausend jetzt Verdachtslose oder.
Test sind oder äh Tests, weil man mein Krankenhaus oder so eine ganze Belegschaft durchtesten will, das wird nicht der Groß der Tests sein, vermute ich sehr stark. So, deswegen größtenordnungsmäßig,
äh hieße das, wir bräuchten also schonenden paar tausend Meldungen, in dem System, bevor es äh zu einer.
Solchen Erfolgsgeschichte bekommt oder zu einer erfolgreichen Warnung, die irgendwas verhindert, aber.
Ja Statistisch gesehen würde ich sagen so
dass es so innerhalb von zwei bis drei Wochen, wenn die Downloads auch noch weiter hochgehen. Na gut, die Leute müssen erstmal auch noch Daten sammeln. Also sagen wir mal, so ich rechne äh mit einem Monat
ungefähr bis äh sowas passiert, wenn's früher passiert, ist ein Glücksfall, wenn wir in einem,
Monat äh noch keinen solchen Fall haben. So würde mich das wundern oder wäre das, dass ihr enttäuschend.
Aber von diesen Größenordnungen musst du ja halt oder können wir halt ausgehen. So.
Gut. Dann warten wir das mal ab und schauen mal, äh wie sich das so entwickelt. Ja, Papa, ich denke, wir sind äh dann am Ende dieser Sendung angekommen, oder? Ja, gut.
Ich denke auch, ja, hoffen wir, dass.
Mit den Zahlen, dass sich das irgendwie wieder in andere Bahnen,
begibt und sich der Trend, der sich da abzeichnet nicht konsolidiert.
Ja, weil sonst, ich habe ehrlich gesagt auch persönlich keine Lust irgendwie wieder
auflocker. Ich glaube kein Niemand. Glaube ich kennen niemanden, der da Lust drauf hat, obwohl ich den äh wohl das durchaus interessant war. Viele haben mal inne gehalten. Ich hab
vielen Leuten auch durchaus gehört, auch zumindest die, die keine Kinder hatten, oft war eigentlich
ganz ganz nett und arbeite doch sowieso lieber zu Hause und ja
aber auf der anderen Seite natürlich möchten wir uns schon dann wieder gerne auch ausgehen oder sich mit Leuten treffen oder mal irgendwohin fahren äh in den in den Urlaub
äh und so und äh ja, ich würde.
Machen wir dann auch erstmal. Ja, schauen mal, wie wir, wie wir durchkommen. Also, Leute, das war's, äh, heute von UKW, danke Pavel.
Danke, Tim.
Und äh ja, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Vielen Dank fürs dabei bleiben. Vielen Dank für eure Unterstützung durch Kommentare und durch äh Spenden selbstverständlich.
Wir hören uns hier mit diesem Format dann vermutlich so in einer Woche oder vielleicht auch ein paar Tage mehr, müssen wir mal gucken, wie sich das jetzt alles entwickelt. Äh wieder und ja, bis dahin habt.